so the governor of New Mexico
she banned guns last week and a judge
wrote yeah you can't do that so like any
Tyrant trying to rule by decree she has
now issued a narrow public order that
recognizes and respects the judge's
ruling but this new order banned guns in
places where families or children may
gather
yeah she's still trying to ban guns and
you've got the media being like she's
narrowed the the band and lifted it no
she she didn't you can argue that she's
narrowed the decree but she is trying to
this is what Cuomo did when the courts
were like you can't shut down churches
he goes okay here's a new executive
order for another reason we can shut
down churches sue me because now we have
to keep going to court over and over and
over again even though she knows she's
lost these people out of their minds we
got really big news today and it's crazy
not surprising though because it's
Friday and they want to bury a lot of
stories three men who are charged with
attempting to kidnap Gretchen Whitmer
have been acquitted on all charges
yeah it was a hoax we got the special uh
prosecutor special counsel trying to gag
order Donald Trump
and then we got this crazy video you've
got people in New York protesting
ocasio-cortez because of the illegal
immigrants and she's yelling over them
being like don't worry once we give them
all work visas it will be better and
then they just yell louder yeah she's
totally out of her mind we'll talk about
that but before we get started head over
to timcast.com click in the menu bar
timcast irlx Miami or the link in the
description below come to our Miami
event we hope to see you there we're
gonna have a whole bunch of special
guests but October 6th at 6 p.m we got
Tim Poole Lew gradkowski your hosts with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and of course the whole Tim cast
crew is going to be there and a whole
bunch of other other people are showing
up I don't know if I should shout out
who's going to be there just yet because
we're still waiting but I don't I I kind
of don't want to but I think Alex
Stein's gonna I'm gonna be there pimp on
a blimp is going to be in Miami with my
thong bikini
I don't know anymore Maybe please Tim
it's so friendly this is gonna raise
your ESG score all right well uh but
there's maybe in like a few days we'll
we'll bring out the full list of special
uh special guests and there's probably a
few people who jump up on stage people
you know and love prominent individuals
in in journalism on you know good
journalism and other personalities so
definitely check that out but also click
join us become a member because get this
even though we don't do the uncensored
shows on Friday as a member you get
access to the members only uncensored
shows Monday through Thursday every day
Monday through Friday in the Tim cast
members Discord servers the members host
another after show so there's the after
dark show Monday through Friday and that
means on Friday if you want to discuss
the show its contents with other
like-minded individuals sign up today
join the Discord and you can hang out
and get another entire podcast being
because our members are super cool and
they literally just talk about this
stuff so I hope you join and become
friends you can follow the show at
timcast IRL smash the like button
subscribe share it all that good stuff
we got a bunch of really awesome people
hanging out obviously you know Alex
Stein's already here pimp on a blimp
thank you for having me Tim always a
pleasure absolutely actually Sinclair's
here hello hello
everybody already knows who both of you
are but I don't know if you wanted to
well I do want to shout out I'm I say
Claire I work at the Babylon bee and I'm
the author of a quote-unquote anti-trans
children's book elephants are not Birds
um you should check it out but the
battle on B also has a new book out or a
guide to gender so right on and I'm
prime time alexana I have a show on
Blaze TV called prime time without sign
and I have a pro-trans book uh a penis
can be a vagina is what my book is
called We're actually we're working on
coffee for for Alex signature cat it's
going to be uh I think it's called Alex
Stein Primetime grind two times caffeine
Prime Time grind extra caffeine because
I know you guys are you guys need it for
work we all need it for work we're tired
you're gonna drink some of this
caffeinated Java and you're gonna feel
great and it's going to give you that
clean High not the hunter Biden fentanyl
high that you're used to with well it's
an upper not a downer but so we got
phillipant how you doing I'm Phil Avanti
leasinger of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter revolutionary
Ian do you caffeinate Alex before some
of your iconic news conferences where
you step in I mean yeah I'm addicted to
diet coke so yeah I'm I mean
I heard a rumor that the the grind is
going to come with a free uh
prescription for Adderall as well yes
you don't legal legal it's prescription
it's from a description I'm not saying
we're giving away everything illegal no
I'm just trying to suck some coffee over
yeah
Ian's here of course of course yes and
sir just pressing the buttons I am
pressing buttons we're all in now let's
go for it let's go we got this story
from Santa Fe New Mexican Governor
Alters Public Health order ending gun
ban in Albuquerque area talk about a
garbage lie of a headline because what
does it actually say first of all they
bury it a week after declaring a public
health emergency blah blah blah is an
announcement of the changes during a
news conference blah blah blah and then
you go all the way down and it actually
says that uh she added the ban on
carrying firearms open or concealed will
remain in place at parks and playgrounds
where families and children gather that
is to say she is issuing a new order to
bypass the courts trying to still ban
guns you can't do it but she's trying
we're winning impeachment impeach
convict indict prison I don't know if
that's is it even after like is there is
this enough of a reason to impeach a
certain governor for trying to make it
up yes then do it do it this is number
two strike two you're gonna let this
woman strike out she's she's
intentionally trying to violate
constitutional rights and she continues
so now this is the second attempt so
impeacher just start the process get her
out of there but it's a Democrat
Trifecta State it's never going to
happen fair enough I I don't think that
there's going to be that's why she's
doing it yeah because they're because
she's insulated which is a problem which
speaks to a problem that that we have in
the country that if your party does
something wrong we just ignore it if
your party or if you're opposing party
even comes close to stepping on the line
then you have to throw the book at him
which is a massive problem in a liberal
Society well I think it really what it
highlights is that we think we can fix
all these problems at a federal level
when covid showed you that when you
fight it at a lower level even the state
level that's actually where you make
change now I'm not saying that she
should be able to supersede the
Constitution but this is why it's so
important to I mean we care about the
president but it actually matters who
your Governor is it matters who your
mayor is so I mean for me I think it
just kind of shows you how the smaller
level of politics is almost more
important because these people aren't
going to follow rules they're going to
do whatever they want so it's really
important you put people that are
actually making the decisions for your
state that you like but she's ruining
New Mexico this is something that we
talk about a lot is how important local
politics yeah I got to be honest I think
the voters have ruined New Mexico yeah
that's fair although maybe maybe they've
tried to poison the country but this is
an inoculate of success in my opinion I
mean I there's the argument that when
they make power power grab moves it is
bad for us no matter what it's not a
victory like Kyle right now is not
Victory the fact they they put them over
the coals and all that stuff is a loss
and I'm like
yes in this instance though I wonder if
it actually is a victory in that you're
watching the feeble pathetic nature of
you know Democrat decree it is it is
powerless and impotent and they tried
and failed and are being mocked for it
and it's actually hurt them so I think
this is a victory and it's almost like
you know she made this move
slipped in a banana peel landed in in
you know in a bunch of dog crap on the
ground and everyone's laughing at her
for it and she's now she's getting like
no you can't laugh at me and then she
slips again yeah and we're just like wow
this is hilarious well I think she likes
the publicity but I mean honestly a lot
of this is Jesse Pinkman and Walter
White's problem if they would have made
all that crystal meth in New Mexico I
don't think we'd have this problem yeah
they gave Albuquerque a Bad Name They
gave Albuquerque a bad thing it used to
have like southwestern salsa with like
corn in it now it's now you'd go to
schlotches at the Albuquerque Turkey and
now it's just a what is it called
Albuquerque Turkey it's delicious on the
sourdough bread turkey lettuce tomato
sauce
yeah I know but yeah that's not based on
New Mexico that was in Chicago no but
I'm saying they have the Albuquerque
Turkey it's one of their uh you know
signature sandwiches my point because it
was a bad joke but uh like Mexico well
and Netflix is in New Mexico now I
wonder if that has with their
headquarters yeah or they have a big
Studio really
yeah oh yeah Schlotzsky's is based in
Texas it's so good yeah it's actually
pretty good yeah yeah yeah yeah stream
they got like um Rubens yeah oh dude
they have a real I love the Albuquerque
Turkey you say I was just turned into an
ad for schlotsky's in like 20 years the
Netflix has eight sound stages at the
Albuquerque Studios yeah it's pretty
cool so what what are you saying well
that's just kind of turned into liberal
hollywood-esque
I like that but this Governor see that's
the thing is she's realizing she's
getting clicks and she's getting a lot
of heat from it they like heat damn they
don't care if it's bad publicity there's
no such thing oh I think she looks
foolish she had even Democrats like Ted
Lou coming out yeah Ted Lou I think she
looks I think she understands she looks
foolish which is why she's doubling down
but what's interesting is she cites
increased gun deaths as the reason for
doing this and now you can't have them
at public parks or anywhere where
children are but I just looked up their
stats it says on average 33 children and
teens die by guns each year in New
Mexico 49 percent of those are suicides
so I don't know what she expects to
accomplish by Banning them in Parks
didn't she specifically say nothing
because she said that she didn't expect
criminals to stop carrying guns yeah she
said that in an interview actually
articulated that so it's intentionally
aimed at law-abiding citizens who are
not going to actually be inclined to
break the law and why are they so
obsessed with making everywhere our
children go gun-free zones and making
them targets for it's an excuse tragedy
all it is is an excuse that's it is not
that has nothing to do with child safety
and everything to do with this will get
the soccer moms scared for their kids
and we will get support this way because
Karen doesn't want Little Tommy to get
shot that's it it's all it's all just to
pull on people's emotions well to what
Ashley said though you know how a lot of
the gun deaths are suicide so I have a
way that we can actually decrease gun
violence we just need to adopt Canada's
plan of medically assisted suicide and
then if we just give out free suicides
there'd be less gun violence suicides we
could always do it we could always get
the uh Canada your hip hurts we can
euthanize you I was thinking of the uh
the bullet train that they're trying to
build in California that seems to work
in Japan so
people jump in front of the bullet train
oh my gosh man that's what Logan Paul
the suicide forest like Japan and
actually Japan's suicide is higher than
the United States and they have no guns
so the idea that getting rid of Guns is
going to stop suicides that's not I
think it's mental health most of it is I
mean it stems from mental health at the
very least school shootings particularly
a lot of ssris and stuff that like crazy
chemicals talk about Adderall earlier
like amphetamines on like 12 13 14 year
olds that don't have a dad around to
kind of help them learn how to navigate
their rage
that's a lot of this well and that's the
point if she actually cared about ending
gun deaths maybe she should address that
49 of them are stemming from some sort
of Mental Health crisis well and Ian
what you said you made a really good
point they all are
well but I just want to say this Ian
like you just said I don't even think
it's all about race or class which that
is a big important factor but it comes
down to if you don't have a parent if
you grew up without a dad if you grew up
without a mom I think that's really the
reason mostly a dad they're mostly we we
talked about this on the culture War
show this morning uh that single parent
father homes have lower rates of
criminal activity and drug abuse single
parent mother homes have higher rates
and uh so we don't know exactly know why
but when the dads if when the dad's not
around you will get a child who is you
will hire well we know why because the
dad's not beating the kids that's when
he does but but not even necessarily
that you know obviously the data shows
that a father figure provides something
but my response was I gotta be honest I
feel like a kid who grows up without a
mom probably has more emotional issues
yeah maybe emotionally cold callus
stunted more so than you'd expect from
someone else but we don't track that
because we're not as concerned in the
immediate with the emotional and Social
Development of the kid we're more
concerned with the like the order yeah
that behavior the behavior itself and
that's the lashing out like the dad's
the one not always the one that's gonna
smack you down I'm not saying physically
violent obviously but for whatever
reason the disciplinarian tends to be
the male not always my mind I don't know
if that's true actually I think the
disciplinarian is the yeah I'm talking
about things that aren't congruent with
my family life my dad was like the
liberal artist and my mom was the one
who was always around and was like hell
no you're not put it down down and then
the look you know the look we're like
I'm just amazing Ian's holding a fork
and slowly moving it towards a power
outlet she's like stop put it down he's
like a little closer it's like no I
wouldn't even get that close one you get
one chance in that family that was a
that was a hard disciplined family it
reminds me of one like you see those
videos where the cat is looking at the
owner and just slowly knocking the jar
towards the edge of the table like it's
going to do it you're like my toddler
just that's what my cat Kyle does he
look at me and when he's mad or
something he'll just knock something off
the table to get my attention and he'll
do it when I'm looking at him does your
toddler make eye contact with you while
he's at it now oh you're interested in
that oh yeah he knows he'll point out
something he's not like an outlet and go
no no
he knows but they seek out danger and
death
yeah but anyway you know the the bigger
picture here is let the uh this lady
have her her 15 minutes of infamy I
think she's embarrassing the Democratic
party and I I'd be honest I feel kind of
like you couldn't ask for this kind of
publicity in the inverse right if when
you get David Hogg coming out and
agreeing with you that's all that's all
you need now you can run campaign ads
being like David Hogg says there is no
exception for the Constitution and
defend second amendment rights and stuff
like that that's amazing yeah forever
can we talk about David Hogg though a
little bit about how his dad was an FBI
agent and the fact that he wasn't even
at a Parkland day of the shooting he was
actually riding his bike there well so
he was in a different part of the school
and then he went home and then when he
heard the news had come down he jumped
on his bike and and went straight back
so he was really scared of a school
shooter when there was a school shooter
that's what I do I get my bike and I
drive straight to the school shooter and
it's fascinating because you had uh uh
Kyle kashev kashiv I don't know sorry
Kyle I can't pronounce your name and uh
he was trying to speak up too but they
were like no ignore that kid we don't
want that message yeah yeah because he
was like I was also at the school and
like I think we shouldn't do this and
stuff but uh you know it's all it's it's
it's they David Hogg brilliant kid
absolutely brilliant he is he is a uh
he's one of the best in the business
when it comes to political manipulation
and grifting and spinning in your face
for political power like obviously this
kid knows exactly what he's doing he
acts he does this routine where he's
like oh why won't why won't we we debate
guns and everything and any legitimate
person mystery for instance who's like
let's have a conversation bro ghost and
then he'll try and Target someone who's
completely wrong and Confused has he
ever done it probably not I mean look
he's
a grifter
he he knows he can't win an actual gun
debate that's it end of story I don't
think that's what it is with Democrat
politics that's why they don't engage
and come on shows like this and then
they use that they don't come on shows
like this as an argument against us by
saying he doesn't have people on the
left on his show ever and it's like yeah
you don't come on because you will your
political arguments get get annihilated
well Bill Mitchell he's not on the left
but he did look like a lesbian on your
show to be fair so well that was he was
the one who who mentioned that yeah I
know that was a funny clip I didn't even
know that was a statement until he said
it and then and then he said immediately
after he said I knew the moment I said
it it would be a clip and to to hit to
uh I'll give him respect he ran with it
and he embraced it and he said it and
then he made jokes consistently about
how he thought he looked like an aging
lesbian and I'm like I think I said this
bill Mitchell yes like but look I mean
like if someone makes fun of you and you
roll with it and say well you know then
you know I'll make it the best I can I
can respect that right I think it's
insulting to lesbian and that's not fair
right you know what I mean but it's one
thing to roll with someone making fun of
you while they're doing it another thing
to bring it up later and to insult
yourself you humiliate again like it's
unnecessary to be like I remember all
those people that were saying about me
like because that's not what that's not
how it went down yeah he he had some
zingers and one-liners that were
Throwbacks and I it was pretty funny and
I'll say this for Bill you know when we
we hung out we had sushi wheat dinner
after the culture War show and hang out
with him and Laura was completely
cordial and polite and they laughed and
uh it was like normal conversation
outside of the political space there was
no no trouble getting along and then
once they went back on Twitter it was
just throwing Fireballs again text it's
funny you say that because I had Laura
on my show this week and I thought it'd
be funny my producer actually likes to
santis I had him put under the Santa
shirt I thought oh maybe she'll just
cuss him out she's very cordial and very
nice like you know so he didn't really
want to I was hoping she was gonna tear
him a new but uh let's let's
jump to this uh the story from the post
millennial this is this is huge
three men accused of Gretchen Whitmer
kidnap plot acquitted there you go I
mean what more do you need the last
three men who were charged in the plot
to kidnap Governor Gretchen Whitmer have
all been found not guilty on all charges
by the way William null twin brother
Michael null and Eric moliter were among
the 14 charge in the alleged plot and
three have been acquit and all three
have been acquitted Adam Fox and Barry
Croft Jr were convicted of kidnapping
conspiracy in 2022 the two were also
found guilty of conspiring to obtain a
weapon of mass destruction such as a
bomb to destroy a bridge I just it's
such obvious BS the general let me let
me break down for you how this works the
FBI finds some and then keeps
whispering things to him like don't you
want to do this come on don't you want
to do this and they'll be like nah not
really in the black monster anyway and
they'll be like no not really just get
in the car and like okay ah he got in
the car that proves it and then this is
happened in Ohio when I was living there
2012 you can look this up I mean it's
just it is just like more corroborative
evidence that this happens more than
what it's not like a one-off three
sentenced to prison for plot to blow up
Ohio Bridge they were given explosives
dummy explosives by FBI undercover FBI
agents gave these three dudes fake
explosives and apparently colluded with
them it's the same as a controlled drug
by I want Donald Trump to criminally
charge all FBI agents who participated
in these conspiracies
yeah but that's what the FBI does is
they'll set you up like oh we have a
cocaine dealer and they'll set you up
the cocaine dealer and the cocaine
dealer's an FBI agent so I mean it was
all set up but we're never going to get
any transparency with the FBI I mean I
think the FBI and CIA killed JFK I I do
not want Trump to go in it should be
like we're we're trying to get Dad we're
defied to get no I want to be like whoa
hold on yes yes but first audit and
criminal indictments for any and all FBI
agents who were party to criminal plots
and you know what there's a lot of them
we don't know about
I'd imagine more because you look at
what happens with the Whitmer thing how
many times have has the FBI engaged in a
conspiracy to say kidnap a politician
and then not convince anyone to join
them so we pulled those records and we
say ah we got an agent John Smith right
here looks like you engaged in a plot to
arrest a a mayor or to to kidnap a mayor
and the black well yeah but we're doing
this thing well it says here you're the
one who initiated it put your hands
behind your back shut your mouth you
have the right to remain silent lock
them up
That's a hardcore dude but you know
those The Men Who were just what were
they acquitting they should be thankful
that the jury was able to learn about
these Rogue FBI informants because most
people in that position wouldn't have
that is what the FBI does yeah so these
guys have their lives dangling off the
edge of a cliff while these FBI agents
smirk and give the Kubrick stare and
laugh about it yeah I I am I am done
playing these games this is abject evil
there is no no legitimate reason for the
FBI to make fake plots and then try and
trick people to do them it doesn't make
sense these guys if they never met the
FBI would be sitting around drinking
talking smack and being and they'd be
worrying about football instead the FBI
comes in and goads them and coaxes them
gives the materials this is what we see
across the board with all these
different plots I say arrest and
criminally charge indict all of the FBI
agents because they are party to the
conspiracy you can't I think the law
should even be amended that says you
cannot charge someone
uh under this law unless the plan was
created outside of law enforcement if if
law enforcement agencies create the plot
then that should be fruit of the poison
tree and none of these men should be
able to be convicted that's like all
sting operations no it isn't no it's not
maybe no it's not wrong so I'll tell you
that not sting here's here's what some
of what the FBI has done
well entrapment is when you when you
knowingly when the person is is being
forced to by either by blackmail
extortion or otherwise but what the FBI
has done which is more questionable but
not in this territory tend to be a drug
dealer no they go to church they go they
go to mosques and they just hang up and
then they wait to see if anyone says
anything and then they leave and there
are a bunch of stories where I've heard
I've heard these stories you can look
them up where there were imams in like
Dearborn who reported the feds to the
FBI immediately when the guy came in and
said hey here's what I'm thinking they
were like oh okay have a nice day and
then Emily called the FED said this
guy's crazy get him out of here and
they're like all right all right right
they leave that is bad those are crazy
stories that cop that that FBI guy
should be arrested for doing that but if
all they do is we are going to have a
criminal informant tell us if
something's going on I got no problem
with that right we want to stop
legitimate acts of Terror what we do not
want is the feds creating the plot and
then trying to trick people into joining
it that right there at the moment it's
discovered who came up with this plan
agent agent Smith okay charges dismissed
Case Closed man you're all free to go
give it Tim Joe Rogan talks about it you
know this in January 6 we probably know
this is they have agent provocateurs
where they can go in in to a riot or to
a protest and actually accelerate things
make things worse and we never hold them
accountable and it's a it's an actual
crime to lie to an FBI agent well and
and even outside of the context of an
investigation so Michael Flynn was
criminally charged even though he wasn't
being formally questioned that's
ridiculous it's like it's like you're
hanging out he was they were hanging out
like a dinner or something in the white
house and they were like so you know
tell me about this and he's like oh you
know X Y and Z and they're like we got
him he just lied to us that's it
yeah you're not even under formal
investigation if you lie to an FBI agent
let me let me I want to ask you Alex why
why uh how come Owen Shroyer is getting
60 days in jail
and the reason is the prosecution said
he he yelled death to tyrants he said
Democrats are tyrants and yelled at the
tyrants uh and Ray Epps who quite
literally said to go into the building
several times was charged with nothing
the the argument about the government
was
Owen Shroyer didn't didn't go in to the
Capitol but he didn't need to the people
he was goading on did uh Ray Epps is the
guy who orchestrated walked around
saying to do it
what's going on well for me the biggest
red flag is when you see the New York
Times and you see Adam kinzinger and you
see all these left-wing people or Adam
kinsinger fake left Winger or fake right
wing or whatever you want to uh fake
both yeah fake both but my point is when
the mainstream media is running cover
for Ray Epps that's the biggest red flag
possible that just makes it seem like oh
this guy's definitely an agent
provocateur but with Owen I mean it's
his connection to Infowars they have to
take him down and they were not going to
give him probation they have to send a
message by making him go to jail but
what's ridiculous is Richard A Barnett
he's the guy that put his feet on Nancy
Pelosi's desk I think he got seven years
yeah I mean when you're in your 60s and
you get seven years I mean that's that's
almost life yeah and when these guys let
them into the building yeah I know those
mag walks you had to turn off those mag
locks I mean but the cops opened the
door those videos
yeah I mean they're walking on Shaman
was just having a nice stroll through
this he was it was it was walking around
confused and the cops gave him
directions and opened they opened the
door for him they were telling him where
to go but that's that's an inside job
and AOC is right when she said that some
of these cops were in on it I'm like yes
I think the the Republicans should start
arresting all these cops and I mean it
100 percent
what what you need to do is stop
allowing the frogs to boil right all of
us are always sitting in this pot and
slowly slowly getting hotter so nobody
moves and then we go from in 2018
there's some street fights to in 2023
they've indicted the president 94 times
or does 94 charges on several different
indictments they're arresting lawyers
and journalists and it's just like okay
how do we get to this point it's because
it's incremental here's what you do
Republicans Matt Gates they won't do it
because they're like oh but we don't
want to piss off cops you in you you
immediately say we're going to uh I we
agree with Democrats January 6 was a
problem here's a video of the police
letting them in and and and helping the
Q Anon Shaman these police aided and
abetted the Insurrection and we need to
get to the bottom of this subpoena the
cops and then criminally charge them and
make them go into the prisons with the
j6ers each and every one every single
cop especially the one who shot Ashley
Bennett no questions
you just do it and then what happens uh
oh now you're going to have the Capitol
Police going to Democrats being like
what did you do with this can of worms
why are we involved in this and there's
not going to be a public you get AOC on
your side right away the first thing I
do is I go to OC and say how would you
like to indict the cops who helped the
j6ers she's going to say yes she's
already on camera saying it's a problem
then you put it in Pelosi's face and you
put in the democrat's face being like
you're right all of these cops that help
these people come in we're going to lock
them up too now you've created a a
problem for Democrats in that the Press
now becomes the Capitol Police that they
they championed cherished and celebrated
are all going to jail too
turn it back on them turn it back on
them yeah but that's never gonna happen
I mean well it's not a question of never
gonna happen it's I'm saying this that's
what it should be done you know I I tend
to agree with you we should hold these
people the only the only thing that's
going to stop this stuff though is I
think it's actually like abolishing
bureaucracy get rid of the FBI or fire
everybody
I'll tell you it says everybody says
abolish the FBI I agree did there has
been a weaponization of our doj and all
these three letter agencies but how do
you do that I don't know that any
president really could go in and
actually do it well uh wasn't the FBI
created by decree I don't know that
they're going to be able to dismantle
that the last person who tried was shot
in the head in Texas so what they're
going to do is they're just going to
have a and I wouldn't be surprised if
law enforcement this is probably not
going to happen very soon but just like
with covet how we had the contact
tracing apps they're gonna have like law
enforcement contact tracing apps for the
phone they're gonna be able to look in
your phone they're gonna know if you're
doing anything illegal they're gonna be
no artificial intelligence will be able
to scan your text messages listen to
your phone calls so we won't even need
the traditional cops like you think and
it'll almost need like you and social
workers I mean there are some good
things that the FBI does you know
nothing good exploitation no you know
they you know didn't Oklahoma City
Bombing not good I think I think Ballard
said he worked with FBI on trafficking
stuff I'm not saying every FBI agent is
bad but I'm just the majority of their
work no it's just it's just a bad
organization the idea that the federal
government needs to have a police force
like you you can argue that the federal
for like Secret Service to protect the
the president and maybe for Capital
police and stuff like that but the
entire like all every state has State
Police and they're all capable of
working together they're all capable of
of sharing information it is not
necessary police are a problem fair
enough but he's forcing all the covets
actually everybody's saying you're a
FedEx it's fine you're right and it's
that's that's totally true but again
it's it's still decentralizes the
problem becomes the centralization of
power in Washington everybody knows that
Washington does not have the individual
people or the state's best interests at
heart Washington is concerned with
Washington and that's the way it's
always going to be as long as uh as long
as power is centered there now I've
heard people talk about moving bureaus
and bureaucracies and stuff to other
parts of the country and maybe there's
an argument for that but really just get
rid of it get rid of it cut it out you
may abolish it it's a good point that
it's the dangers the organization of it
itself yeah the way it's organized the
centralization essentially of top-down
Authority that one guy known as Merrick
Garland or who is he not the head of the
FBI uh he's the yeah he's the he's the
Attorney General he's not the head of
the FBI but he's the head of the justice
department you get these tops giving
these author giving all the soldiers
basically their marching orders all
these Capitol Police are told let them
in we don't want him to break all the
windows just open the doors and let them
in so the cops stand back that's why I
when according to what how you were
saying Tim about arresting him I I tend
towards like what they did to the Nazis
is you arrest the ringleaders you arrest
the ones at the top and then the other
ones you know they're basically going to
be your soldier as well but there
there's videos of these cops opening the
doors and saying come on in I I think
that if we if the Republicans right now
there's a video of this say I want to
know who those cops are you bring them
in for open public Congressional
testimony say why did you open the door
and let them in let them say it on
C-Span to be repost and rebroadcast by
everybody on Twitter the officer says we
did open the doors then you can say okay
the question now becomes officer you let
them in and some of these people have
been in jail for two and a half years
how long how much time in prison do you
deserve for being the one who opened the
doors let the public decide should these
officers go to prison because if you say
no we must release the Jason
investigation because you could get
those cops and be like I was told by my
commanding officer by name
it would be an easy chain of command to
figure out how those doors got open but
I do want to congratulate the FBI on one
thing because they did great police work
when they found two passports on 911 of
the terrorists they weren't able to find
the black boxes but they were able to
find this passport so that was well they
got really lucky that they didn't get
burned up in the explosion I know thank
you they must have fallen out of the
plane before it hit the building because
they found it a couple blocks away
it can be blown away I mean a lot of
debris went very very far that's true
they were blown out the sides of the
buildings A lot of that debris oh I mean
in the initial crash debris was launched
like hundreds of yards it's crazy but uh
they were just lucky that they they
didn't yeah the password just went
through the nose cone of the building
and then two blocks down the
you know why I'm really impressed with
that because I lose my passport all the
time yeah we need my own house you just
need to hire an FBI agent
S
no but like I'll put it like I have like
I'll put in the safe or something and
then we'll travel so I take it out and
then we'll put it in a suitcase and then
we'll come back and put the suitcase in
the room and I'll be like wait it was it
in the bag or was it oh and I gotta tear
the whole bag up and I'm like no I put
it back in the other in the shop then
I'll open and there it is you know but
it's hard sometimes because you I don't
use it that often or call your FBI agent
they'll know well you know when uh maybe
they could work with that because they
weren't able to find the swatters who
swatted us 15 times but but anyway but
the FBI back to the main the main point
all right
when I think about things like this like
hey bring in these cops and have them
testify how come how come nothing like
this ever happens even when it comes to
impeachment it is the most mundane and
predictable thing you can expect from
the GOP there's there's evidence it's
been around for years that we've known
about with Hunter Biden in 2019 Politico
wrote Biden Inc we we we have that whole
all of it laid up by a journalist and
now four years later it's like let's ask
this question it's like where's anyone
to be like I am going to file a subpoena
for all of the police officers and make
them come testify I just
I really don't think
anyone ever does anything it's so boring
I mean I I gotta I just I don't
understand this man
about anything in life I I just don't
understand why nobody does anything and
I'm and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
say this to the extreme I mean this in
the most literal sense to the most
extreme degree no one does anything now
I'll clarify what I mean by that because
obviously we all do different things but
I mean there are prominent powerful
people with lots of money who you'll
hear complain and then do literally
nothing because you answered it because
they're powerful prominent people with
lots of money that's my point that's why
they don't do anything because they want
to continue being prominent powerful you
don't you don't lose that feeling
absolutely Elon Musk does stuff
and he's I I think it's massively
beneficial for him I mean granted he's
getting sued yeah no they're coming out
from doj's coming after but they don't
do anything because it's not they don't
want to they'd rather go on the news and
line their pockets and increase their
net worth by 100. I think they should be
sent to the barracks when they serve an
office they're NPCs they're not allowed
to leave they should be in the barracked
they are NPCs and I tell you this
because
I know people who go on more adventures
and take more risks who are lower income
than wealthy individuals in this country
and in this world there's very few
people who are willing to take large
ridiculous risks in order to affect some
kind of positive change and it's like at
the top of my head who can I even think
of Elon that's maybe it can you yeah
but even he had I mean I like Vivek but
I mean he even had a pharmaceutical deal
that went bad so I mean he's not no no
but he's made a lot of money yeah in
terms of doing crazy stuff like big
boisterous things like Vivek is he's
doing something if he's saying he's
going to end the FBI he's basically
putting himself in JFK's position oh I
love it I I think that's taking a huge
risk just so we can or clear Tim is not
saying that he loves the idea of vague
being in JFK's position specifically
that he would do that and that he's not
in JFK there's a different place in time
I love that he's stepping up and saying
I am willing to put my face out there
with these statements taking all the
risks that come along with it because
it's the right thing to do yes well
outrageous after this pandemic I have an
idea okay I just want to hire a hundred
clowns to like run around Vegas
well how about we just how about Alex we
get you on 100 maybe okay maybe a
thousand we hire A Thousand Clowns
extras yes and you just they just will
do what you ask them to put FBI
informant in it don't do it yeah I know
remember remember when Oprah had the I
got a feeling song and it turned out
everyone in the audience were actually
dancers yeah I was talking about having
clowns to a street show to like be
comedic and and generate attention on
some issue you guys go to Dark Places
yeah inside jobs
yeah a bunch of clowns is gonna be like
it was worse than January 6th the clowns
stormed the building the makeup was
terrible I want to make this point
though is is it sounds so bad and this
is I hope it doesn't get me in trouble
but I've lost almost all faith in
humanity after the pandemic like I think
the Dumber who has the bigger the group
gets the Dumber it gets so that's why
like I'm almost empathetic to the elites
that don't want to interact with us oh
dude I I totally get more Bill Gates I'm
saying I get where Bill Gates he's like
just give him all the vaccines shut up
just you know go about your business no
hold on hold on
anybody who's run a large company
understands the frustrations of what can
go wrong will go wrong and you know like
running this company there are things
that happen where it's like I am
genuinely shocked that something
happened like I don't understand how
explicit instructions of Take A to B and
then do c turns into X Y and Z and I'm
like I how did this how did this happen
and no one has an answer and I'm like
experiencing that I'm like ah so now so
so now I get it Bill Gates with his you
know how many hundred thousand employees
at a certain point his just eyes his
eyes are bleeding they're bloodshot and
he's like why did you put the mop in the
server room and it's just like I I don't
know CERN is
that explodes
because most humans we are I I hate to
admit it we're all kind of dumb I bet if
you asked 10 people on the street
S 80 probably wouldn't know who Kamala
Harris is probably two people I mean the
majority wouldn't so people just not
dialed in they're they're dead they're
you know have a ex-girlfriend baby mom
or whatever just they're they're not
dialed into what's really happening in
the world because they're so distracted
and we're all basically dead slaves just
trying to make it I I do in all
seriousness I do think people like Bill
Gates and a bunch of the other wealthy
powerful Elites
I I think if you were to talk to them
for one they're malthusian they do think
there's too many people and they will
legitimately tell you I mean I'm sure if
you're hanging out at Bilderberg with a
lot of these powerful International
Elites and politicians they're going to
say look man
think about how stupid the average
person is okay now realize half of them
are stupider than that and they vote and
that's like so that's half of that the
first half was George Carlin but that's
probably what they're thinking and
they're thinking we don't want stupid
people to have political power and so
what do you get
look at what's going on with everything
politically in terms of uh abortion
sterilization Etc this is not not a
detriment to conservatives who are more
resilient more uh self self uh Reliant
and protective of their kids it's it's
mostly detrimental to Urban liberals the
covid lockdown policies mostly
negatively impacted Urban liberals all
the things we see defund the police bad
for liberals conservatives and then the
people flee to more conservative areas
where they can be more resilient and and
you know resolved and then it is the
leftists who are suffering tremendously
under their own policies that's
resulting in them and then in them
having less kids yeah I I understand
that but you know people having less
kids is bad for society and civilization
in general yes but if conservatives have
twice as many kids which they're
probably going to start doing then
problem solved but we can never have
more kids in Venezuela's having I mean
they have a culture I mean seriously
they have a culture I doubt they're
doing a lot of abortion so they can just
let people come in from other countries
my biological stepdad Tucker Carlson you
know gets a lot of heat for saying the
great replacement Theory but I don't
know it would be hard to debate that if
you really look at our immigration
policy this is a really good idea powder
PC says to send 100 clowns to DC each
with a senator's name and badge and
whenever they see the senator they go
there and they start dancing and that's
actually a really good idea to just have
like you know someone wait outside and
then when they see the center walking
the car the clown starts is behind
camera going like dude that would be
funny with kids and like the value of
having children
um equating to like the species
propagating I wonder if there's a
there's got to be a diminishing return I
I think that like yeah you can have four
kids that's maybe better than having
three but if you have 19 kids you don't
have time for 19 kids a lot of those
kids are going to grow up without a
parent so like that's worse the siblings
help a lot yeah in all situations like
in the past like people like families
have have had as many kids as they could
in the like anticipating some of them
dying off so you could you can still
manage to raise like bees that's what
bees do they have a ton of babies and
then a bunch die but some survive the
point is though but like a hundred years
ago families were much larger before any
kind of birth control people weren't
like no we don't want to have sex
because we might have kids like they
were still getting it on and you had big
families and stuff like this let's let's
I want to segue this because it's a
overpopulation families and stuff is a
good a good way to say I went to the
story we have this from timcast.com
protesters chant send them back at AOC
during NYC press conference an estimated
110 000 illegal immigrants have arrived
in the city since 2022. this story is
fascinating and the video is even more
fascinating take a look at this you
gotta you gotta hear this let's play it
yeah and ultimately I think that there
are three points of consensus here that
are very important in getting a solution
to this issue the first is that there is
there is consensus here across geography
and States on increased Federal
resources to cities and municipalities
dealing with this issue consensus listen
authorization okay how to play that
again
the second is to allow for work
authorizations so that the folks in here
can get to work and start supporting
themselves as soon as possible AOC is
abject evil and you can hear these
people screaming at her and what is her
response to them don't worry we're going
to give them work rights so that they
can displace your wages lower your wages
displace your jobs
have a nice day they are prevented from
getting jobs they are prevented from
employment and that is part of the
strain on our public system the faster
that folks can access the work that
they're asking for legally the better we
can solve this problem and the third is
extension of temporary protected status
look at this
she is so evil that people are screaming
at her and protesting across the board
in these cities and what does she say
we're going to spend more Federal
resources on them we're going to give
them work rights and protected status
over you while they're screaming at her
send them back now those are her
constituents yes hopefully yeah so those
are the people she's representing yep
yeah no I know
I mean everybody they're freaking out
about it Curtis Lee was been arrested
protesting this a bunch I mean this is a
big deal that they're actually vets that
they're kicking out of hotels to put
these illegal immigrants in that makes
no sense why would a vet that went and
risk their life in Iraq be less uh
likely to get Social Services than an
immigrant from Venezuela I'm sorry to
tell you Alex uh ocasio-cortez not you
Alex
yo you are not here to govern the world
an illegal immigration it's not your job
your job is to protect and serve the
United States and the Citizens United
States lady
that's not her job their her
the Democrats want us to just be one big
globalist homogeneous job it's got to
happen
that's why she's an international
communist like even though she's a
representative from New York she's a
member of the DSA and she's an actual
communist but they don't believe in
borders they don't believe in Nations
they they think that if you believe in
borders you're a nationalist and a
nationalist means you're a Nazi she's a
communist and that's the the reason why
she wants to have all the the free open
borders when you say she doesn't believe
in borders you mean she just envisions
them differently the Democratic
socialists of America think that there
should be no borders at all but then you
would have no states exactly right no
cities
that's what communism is communism is a
global thing like when they say real
communism has never been tried it's
because there has never been a full
Global communism So when you say the
Soviet Union was communism they tried
communism it didn't work then the
Communist reply is cut real communism
has never been tried and the reason it's
never been tried is because it was not
Global there was class there was Nations
and as long as that is the situation
it's not real communism
the new world my favorite is when you
ask a communist like what do they want
they go I usually like Star Trek yeah
and I'm like Oh you mean post-scarcity
world where you can tell a computer to
just fabricate something from free
energy from from Ambient Energy and it
does bro I'll tell you this yeah
property when we get to the point where
we have replicators and you can
literally be like computer ham sandwich
and then it does sure we can have some
agreements on labor reforms at that
point but spare me this utopian Vision
while 100 million people over the past
you know 100 some odd years were
murdered in Mass even then man when that
replicators in action who built the
replicator what is the replicator's code
replicator Builder replicator so is the
replicator giving you actual water when
you say water or is it giving you
something slightly different and it's
slightly better it's gonna be like Delta
nine weed all the real weed that's what
I'm talking about large large
complicated replicators replicate small
replicators what they do is there's
Ambient Energy they absorb and then it
it fuses the particles together to make
the appropriate elements and then that's
that's the world of science fiction hey
maybe one day we'll get there and if we
do we can have conversation about Labor
reforms and then we can talk about how
everybody just has unlimited food and
all this stuff and then what's going to
happen is the Communists are going to
say too many people are eating food
getting fat and having babies and then
you know What communists do they do what
they always do
well Communists have a history of just
murdering Millions upon millions of
people oh we don't have enough food face
the wall please but it's not even that
when there's too much food they're going
to be like okay now that food is
infinite Supply or near infinite and
people are eating too much of it and
they're getting sick we gotta we gotta
deal with the with the like they're
going to excise the people they deem to
be wrong it's this this world doesn't
exist where they think I love that Meme
where someone said what what do you what
are you going to do once communism is
achieved and they said I think I'll
teach people how to do poetry on my farm
and maybe do art classes and then the
response was your farm
these people don't get it no first order
thinkers and they are gonna they're
gonna be in a world for her the Italian
island of six thousand we talked about
before show I'm not going to say on air
what I was saying before the show
because it's horrific to Envision what
could happen to a massive migrants that
move into a place where they're not
wanted if you don't try and stop it
ahead of time and you just let it keep
happening it's going to get really
really big you could get so bloody okay
you do not want to see that let's let's
talk about the southern border and where
we're at right now New York Chicago
these are liberal bastions freaking out
AOC is getting screamed at one of the
risks that I fear because they are not
properly secured securing our borders
and dealing with the crisis of illegal
immigrants flooding into this into the
system is
these people who are coming in do not
recognize our government governments
fall when the people do not have
confidence in those governments so if
you look at let's go back to we talked
about Lexington and Concord in the
American Revolution when the when the
crown said Massachusetts is in a state
of rebellion and here's what you have to
do the militias outside of Boston says
we don't recognize you and we're going
to do whatever we want because there was
no confidence that they could do
anything and there was a willingness to
reject them let me put it this way
if a guy walks up to you wearing a clown
suit and says I'm from clown division on
your uh put your hands against the wall
you'd be like what no clown division
hands against why would you put your
hands against the wall for someone
showing the clown division badge and
they have a big clown hair and nose and
they go you'd be like bro is this a joke
I don't know who you are and you have no
authority over me you can claim to be
the king you can claim to be the
president that doesn't mean anything I
don't know you what happens when you
import millions of people every year who
do not recognize your government and
your laws at some point you are going to
have large groups of people in New York
who are going to say I don't know you
dude a guy special I'm a cop in there
like what does that mean to me you're in
our territory now I'll give you a real
real world example it's called rinkabee
in Sweden they brought in a whole bunch
of Somali migrants in the 90s they sent
them to these might like they basically
had them all go to the same places there
was no regulation in control as to where
they were going what ends up happening
is the Somali migrant refugees and
migrants who go to this neighborhood of
rinkaby have kids those kids grow up
surrounded by Somali individuals they do
not see the Swedish people or government
as anything to do with them when the
police come in they start throwing
stones and Bricks at the cop saying get
out because they are the authority in
that area and that happened to me when I
went there they didn't throw stones or
anything they started yelling at us and
threatening us and the cops were like
you probably want to leave we'll follow
you out the the simple uh I'll give you
the simple version it's more complicated
than that but I asked them like should
we should go and they're like it's going
to get very dangerous they could start
throwing bricks we can't do anything to
help you and what we were we were told
by the people in the country who are
honest is well when you have a
generation all these young young men who
are in their 20s and they've got no they
they they don't interact with the
government they don't run for office
they're not they don't it's not possible
for them to win office the police don't
come in these areas they don't pay taxes
right and so in their minds Sweden they
are not Swedish they do not live in this
country and the police who come in it
would be no different than if you saw a
dude wearing a badge a clown badge
walked onto your property you'd you'd
like get off my property you're
trespassing and they know I'm from clown
division you'd be like I don't recognize
what that is and don't care you are
trespassing now we as Americans
recognize what law enforcement is the
sheriff the FBI or otherwise but what
happens when you have all of these
non-citizens who are going to be like I
don't know who you are what you're doing
here I do not know the systems of
governance United States I don't know
anything about your laws your
politicians your law enforcement then
what happens on the southern border when
you have these instances occurring in
places like New York and finally in
Texas they say guys
the federal government is not going to
protect our borders and so what does
Texas do I think was it Texas right they
put up the floating barricades in the
rivers Arizona put up the uh the the
chipping containers the federal
government said you have no right to do
this and it's technically true as to how
the government works states don't have
the have the right to deal with
International borders but they're
starting to which means states have
begun to reject and it's and it's been
going on for a while Federal Authority
what happens then when local law
enforcement say we are going to secure
the borders by force because we can't
contain this anymore here's a scenario
Texas is being flooded by non-citizens
non-citizens who are not going to
recognize law enforcement will probably
flee from law enforcement not recognize
taxes and laws and try and work under
the table you're gonna see we are seeing
economic repercussions and economic
damage and crime and drugs not all of
them are bad people but there are a lot
of drugs and child trafficking the feds
won't do enough about it or they're not
doing anything about it so what happens
then when in Texas a local town or a
county sheriff they say we are you hear
this screaming that's going on in Texas
what I'm sorry going out of New York
imagine a scenario in a year from now
where the same amount of screaming is
happening to a sheriff and they're
screaming I don't care what you do but
stop this now then the sheriff says okay
we're going to get a bunch of guys to
the border and we're going to defend the
Border by force if necessary we're gonna
bring cars we're gonna build barricades
the federal government says stop and
they say I don't know who you are what
you're talking about and they do it
anyway
what happens then when conflict breaks
out between the people who are trying to
flood through the border and the people
who are now sick of it this is a path to
violence what you need in this country
is a federal government who says in
order to avoid violence conflict and
crisis we have to have procedural uh we
have to have a process for how we deal
with this we have to deport people we
have to create security barricades and
not let them just come in but they're
doing everything it seems in their power
to escalate things to the point of
social breakdown violence chaos Etc yes
it's gotten so bad in New York City just
even in the past few months you had Lady
Gaga's Dad speaking out and saying
enough is enough they're flowing over
you can't even really walk down parts of
8th Avenue because they're just housing
them there Staten Island
just had one of the migrant shelters
they were using I believe is an old
school you can't even go outside there
because it smells so bad because of the
sewage issue it's all backed up the
neighbors there they don't even want to
leave their house because it smells of
sewage and it reeks and then you have
all these kids who are if I send my kid
to a school in New York City a public
school he has to be vaccinated he has to
have vaccination records these migrant
children they don't that's an issue
because if there's an outbreak of
something like measles it's spreading to
these kids some of them who can't be
vaccinated because they're
immunocompromised they can't get a
vaccine and none of the migrant kids
coming in have to be vaccinated at all
they don't they're not held to the same
standards as the children of citizens
there of New Yorkers of people in this
country they don't they don't care yeah
but you look at a state like Texas guys
and I know everybody thinks Texas is
conservative but now with Dallas Austin
San Antonio and Houston all being
liberal now the great replacement Theory
it's
in Texas we are being affected by
immigration probably worse other than
California and Arizona worse than
anybody in the entire country and it's
done on purpose a state that was likely
conservative in the next 10 years no
doubt will be liberal
they hate the rule of law which is the
only thing that separates us from people
and Tim has Law and Order the rule of
law yes and they load the rule a lot
they want us to just be one globalist
homage who's they
the globalist is this like World
economic Forum yeah Klaus Schwab's
buddies and stuff like I wonder who who
do you guys think they are exactly well
it's a conglomerate of their names even
out there there's people in the Catholic
Church the probably you know Israel
probably you know there's probably a
whole conglomerate of the trilateral
commission I'm just saying there's
Council of formulations
they is really simple it refers to
establishment political and corporate
power so Financial it's Financial stuff
yeah I would say the corporations are
the most powerful in my opinion well
there's also there's also a group of
people especially the Davos types who
you know they call themselves futurists
and this is their job to Future think
and think about what it would be like if
we were all one Global Community James
Lindsay calls it agnostic cult and
that's what it is they're all
essentially uh it's essentially a
religion and they are looking for a one
world government and when you say they
I'm talking about marxists right
actually Neo Marxist right so because
the economics School of Marxism was
proven to not work in the you know with
the fall of the Soviet Union and all of
the countries that have tried socialism
and so neo-marxism is a new approach to
Marxism and you can take all of the
intersectional stuff that you've got and
that is all different like species of
Marxism right and they all have the same
essential goal let me let me take it to
an even weirder spot this is how weird I
am man I believe it's actually satanic
and I think it comes out of the Bible
and it's uh Genesis chapter 11 verse 9.
and if you flip that it's weird that
it's 9 11 but in that it talks about the
Tower of Babel and and that Nimrod
wanted to build a kingdom to heaven to
go kill God and what God did is he made
all the tribes make it where they can
communicate like you know and so
everybody went out the winter you know
Separate Ways so what they're doing now
these people that worship the devil they
want to invert everything in the Bible
so what they're trying to do is they're
trying to reverse engineer nimrod's plan
and build a one world order so we're
under one rule one currency one system
so it's actually satanic I know that
sounds crazy you don't have to believe
in Devils to agree with him because I
don't believe in like Supernatural stuff
but I still think that he's right
because I don't believe it but they do
right yeah they do these people believe
these weird superstitions and I don't
know if all of them do I know that uh uh
Nancy Pelosi said she was a reptilian
this week let's see if you did yeah type
it in type it in oh my gosh she said it
this week she said I'm cold blooded and
I'm reptilian yeah I mean I don't really
think she's a freaking reptile but
something is weird I mean the point that
he's making is the the Gnostic religion
has been around since before like
Christianity and before I can't Google
it because it says it looks like the
results below are changing quickly check
the source is it a trusted topic so she
said it on uh MSNBC I forget whose show
she was on she just said it if you type
in type it on Twitter and Pelosi wrote
because he's probably gonna give you a
bunch of fake stuff but she just said it
this week and type in uh Pelosi Twitter
or Pelosi reptilian but no I do think
it's demonic or satanic I know that
sounds weird but there's something to it
and whether you believe in it or not
like Phil said here we go here we go
let's play it Nancy Nancy Pelosi she's
really really committed to that it's
really sad no I'm not a poor baby I'm
more reptilian cold-blooded and Cohen
will win the election uh we're gonna
take a short break I want to talk to you
what was it
uh we're gonna take a short break I want
to talk to you more about President
Biden
I guess it's impossible to know what
what with only 13 seconds what is she
referring to in the context of being
reptilian in cold blooded she's saying
she's like ruthless in law yeah like
she's gonna go get her like a lizard and
probably she saw the memes of like the
her looking like a lizard Meme and stuff
I'm not as confident in that part
you saw the meme did we ever figure out
if her husband is a homosexual did we
ever figure that out that's still
undeterminate and that's the cool if he
is yeah yeah
I wish that I wish there was more
context so I could understand why she's
saying this I'm assuming she's saying
like I'm ruthless yes that was what I
got out of but like we don't know
let's try it again
uh you know of course you're just gonna
say that but poor baby yeah she's really
really committed
no I'm not a poor baby I'm more
reptilian I don't understand what she's
trying to say to be honest they're being
facetious from the beginning no I get
that but I don't understand it's like oh
she's a poor baby no I'm telling
reptilian I'm like I don't I don't yeah
I don't know what Anderson's probably
saying that other people were saying oh
Nancy's a poor baby and then Nancy's
like hahaha no I'm not I'm a lizard that
I'm gonna go just take the election
that's my guess
okay but we need more context to
understand no we don't she's a lizard
and it's programming hold on hold on
Nancy Pelosi admits she is a reptilian
and that she's cold-blooded fact
Nancy Pelosi did say the quote I am more
reptilian and cold-blooded
yeah so uh if she said it's true right
well there you go she's a lizard it's a
revelation of the methods either lizard
or she's a liar where does The Reptilian
thing come from like why do people think
oh no this is actually a really good one
so David Ike is one of the guys that
kind of founded this and it goes back to
like the Queen's Bloodlines I suppose we
can trace back to Muhammad I don't know
if you know this and Jesus supposedly so
it's like they think and it comes kind
of comes out of the Bible too there's
all this weird mix of like there's a
third of the Angels casted out of heaven
and these were like the Nephilim and
then the Angels slept with these Giants
and then we're kind of the
offspring of it so there's all this kind
of like Whimsical stuff or at some point
Angels made it with the animals here and
that there might be Bloodlines like we
have and there might be Bloodlines where
these angels made of the animals and
they became human so you're saying that
the lizard people are Nephilim kind of
like they're in that Vibe how whatever
the Nephilim Vibe it kind of comes from
that time of this that's where a lot of
it comes the early origins of existence
I mean I'm not saying this is true but
that's what they say and there's there's
something weird though how the queen and
Prince Philip how they live for forever
I mean obviously they have the best
medical doctors but there's something
weird uh about blood I don't know about
Bloodlines I don't know I was just I was
just reading this list of the oldest
people and some like lady was 120 years
old and she was like a nobody in the
middle of nowhere yeah I'm saying some
people break the I mean some people live
a long time but it's just weird that
these billionaires live for a while but
it's not I mean you can say it's weird
in that it's like not suspicious it's
weird that they do but it's obvious what
they're doing like don't they do the the
what are they called blood boys blood
boys blood boys uh there's um like stem
cell treatment stuff that people I've
heard stories of like these super rich
people who well there's that one
millionaire guy anti-asian guy yeah yeah
it was like having a son's blood
transfused into his body or whatever to
be younger and it's like yeah but you're
not gonna get much more longevity out of
these things anyways I mean you might
live a little longer because they have
access to better things but they're
really not increasing their longevity
significantly they don't want to and and
part of the transhumanist stuff is being
able to put your mind in a machine so
you can live forever they're obsessed
with living forever in longevity there's
a part of the The Reptilian Brain called
the basal ganglia that the uh the
reptilia of The Reptilian complex that
humans also have of basal ganglia so at
some point in our Evolution we were
active we were probably had only come
that far and I think what happened
there's this interesting Theory from
this book Ishmael that I got where oh
that book a long time ago yeah it's
pretty close to talking gorilla yeah we
know all about it uh where after
something happened but a huge segment of
humanity went North they migrated Great
Migration a lot of people from the
equatorial maybe it was the great flood
something but they went North they could
no longer grow props I apologize right
there is see the issue is we used to
believe in what was called out of Africa
Theory but I think it's been debunked
already what messages
like life recovered in Mesopotamia and I
think they used to think that's where it
began but that's where it recovered
After the flood they went to like turkey
I think there's definitely a flood oh
yeah 13 12 800 ago there's tons of
evidence like rock wall there's a place
right outside of Dallas it's called
Rockwall in its name because these guys
were digging you know whatever 100 years
ago and they found these huge walls that
were deep underground that make no sense
and if you can't dig it yeah type in
Rockwall Texas and because they're so
deep underground like they think that it
was maybe an Old Fort so there is so and
then what is it uh um what is the
tobekly uh yeah is is what that didn't
even the timeline doesn't even make
sense go back to A Thousand Years yeah
so that's where they went that's where
they recovered to After the flood they
went to go Beckley Tepe or they built it
after the flood but it looked like it
was like an ancient Temple that they all
all these societies went and kind of
congregated at my theory is that these
people that went North after this
cataclysm couldn't grow crops so they
had to hunt constantly all they did was
hunt they hunt killed so they developed
a lizard-like behavior and then their
skin got lighter and lighter and then
eventually they came back south as these
marauding bloodthirsty conquistadors
murdering they colonizing Europe they
took over they eventually became the
Romans and like so this like
bloodthirsty Behavior as opposed to like
eating crops the bloodthirsty behavior
is the lizard oh wow look at this
picture no joke a huge wall was buried
and so there is quite literally a wall
buried in Texas they can't even dig it
up it's so big wow that's really big it
was very big and they have no idea what
it's from there's no evidence they don't
even know what the hell so they just
named the city Rockwall so again look at
this photo here you can see they're
Excavating it and there's it's it's wall
man it's a big wall oh I mean it's mud
flood bro you know about mudflow oh I
mean I'm just saying there's something
weird I mean we probably did have a
flood oh wait wait for those that aren't
familiar that I'll probably be getting a
run with the general idea which you know
obviously I find silly but uh there are
people who believe that there was a
massive ancient civilization a flood
happened wiping everybody out and mud
and sediment and everything shifted
around burying large components of this
ancient civilization and uh not we've
we've begun to discover some of it
there's a the deeper conspiracy is that
we've not built these buildings we've
discovered them and that's why it is
really weird you'll see buildings in
some cities where there's clearly a door
halfway in the ground you've seen those
right and I'm like I don't know why they
built that building that way I don't
think it means that a mud flood happened
and buried the building it's probably
more likely that like Chicago they
lifted the city up things like that
happen well there is weird stuff too if
you look at all the old world's fairs
they used to build be able to build
these beautiful buildings with no power
tools with no modern technology and then
they would just destroy it you know
shortly thereafter or it got burnt out
of fire so I think there's a great fire
Chicago great fire San Francisco a lot
of these classic cities Tim they had
huge fires in around like the 20s or 30s
so we don't even know their own history
so there's something we I'll just say
this I'm a full-blown conspiracy
theorist you don't need to be that but I
think our history is not the truth it's
hold on history is not true that's
that's the end of story yeah end of
story like look at modern news today we
know how it's manipulated exactly and so
we try our best to piece together as
much of history as we can while knowing
that it's written by The Victors I just
I don't believe any of the religions
because of it I can't believe any of
those texts because it's all like less
credible than CNN what's interesting
though is there's so many different
religions that have very comparable
stories like so many different religions
have a story of the flood or Noah and
the arc so I find that fascinating
what if uh you know when the flood
happened it was actually you know what
when was when was the Sphinx underwater
or whatever it was like we're on the
same period like 10 000 years ago 12 000
yeah years ago imagine what it was 12 12
000 BC you're saying uh they said 12 000
800 years ago it's like that's where
this whole go back to Texas all right
all this water damage oh interesting
yeah there's lots of erosion damage on
the side exactly right so you have this
ancient civilization with wonderful
technology the Earth starts flooding and
all the wealthy powerful Elites are like
we out and they just leave earth when
they're gone and all the poor Yoko
working class rednecks get left behind
where most die and those who survive
start to rebuild and here we are today
but I think the real Elites told people
they were gods and like Nephilim and
they still had ancient Tech they had hot
air balloons
but that's an entirely different
conspiracy theory I'm just saying
there's a potential conspiracy theory or
I'm saying my conspiracy that I'm
bringing up right now is nothing to do
with any of that I'm just saying there's
an advanced civilization the ultra Rich
it wasn't Noah some humble guys like I'm
gonna build an arc it was a super it was
a billionaire social media Mogul who was
like I'm building a Starship and then he
he did and then when the flood happened
they left everyone else gets wiped out
those who survived the Water World start
to rebuild and here we are dude they
used to think the Sphinx was was like 3
500 years old well so and now they think
it's like 15 000 years old
by the way we were off a little bit I
think the argument that they carved a
different head into it is it makes a lot
of sense yep one of the Pharaohs came to
face the lion yeah it used to be an
actual cat or or a dog Anubis or
whatever and then they cut the head down
to really small to be the Pharaoh
instead yeah it was like uh it was it
because the Hat doesn't fit the body
size no it's all receded man it was a
beautiful lion I bet carved out of the
out of the mountain you know I think the
sad reality reality is that we want to
believe these things because it gives us
mystery and lore and we can hope that
there's something crazy that might
happen but it's just not yeah we're
incapable of living without myth I was
thinking about going back to like the
800 a BC when the Romans were just
tribes and like 600 BC and if you could
go back to that period and teleport
around place to place time to time and
explore that that's why I want to live
is to be able to do that and I know that
with with like advanced technology I
think we're going to be able to simulate
that kind of experience where you're
actually there with the Romans talking
men are always thinking about the Roman
Empire I mean that's true well you might
you might wait that was a meme right
yeah it's a trend so ask a guy how often
do you think about the Roman Empire and
men are obsessed with the Roman Empire
rightfully so in my opinion but every
day because I follow stoic accounts well
I I wouldn't say every day but a couple
times a week at minimum dude that's
insane that's incredible to me water in
well because from the male perspective
women are basically just sitting around
all giggling with each other about their
hair right yeah and men are all talking
about like ooh ancient Rome you know the
row all roads lead to Rome because
that's so equally silly you know what I
mean yeah well it's funny it's a
serration it's funny Ian you said
something about Advanced Tech but I
think it's very easily provable I mean
you guys might argue with me on this I
think we're getting Dumber really fast
because if you look at just like the the
stone work that they did in New York
City not that long ago like the
Gargoyles and corners of buildings it's
amazing we can't even recreate that
today with all the technology we have we
can't make our girls what do you mean no
are you they can't recreate a lot of the
classic gargoyles and classic like uh
whatever stone work they've done come on
dude I'm dead
Google it I'm telling you there's like
the pyramids we can't build the pyramids
today they don't know how they build
experiments you can we can't Google if
we can build a pyramid
we cannot build the pyramids today
Google it Google it the way they build
this pyramids we cannot
I watched the video where a middle-aged
fat dude was was moving multi-ton Stones
he would he would dig him through sound
or whatever though he would dig a hole
under uh under a portion of it and then
he would start rocking it until it
flipped itself over and he was like I
can move it and he started putting these
things together it was like Ancient
Aliens or whatever but we could tell the
pyramid we could not recreate have you
been to the luck sir according to
Wikipedia yes it is
a Wikipedia say concrete they don't even
understand how they built it now I don't
know if they use him create they don't
know what they use to build them back
then
yeah that's what you're gonna say this
in real life too so yeah that's not good
we can't do it in the same way not do it
in the same way these guys are smarter
than us even though dude
Freemasons or whatever they're not we're
not as talented as we are today we used
to be smarter that's a ridiculous
Prospect I I watch that's a true
statement I watch hair I watched
somebody create the pyramid where they
used a stream of water to slice a
screwdriver in half I'm pretty sure we
can easily cut stone and stack it up no
the Burj Dubai you can't yes you can't
just like we can't go we can't check hey
chat fact check me we can't recreate the
pyramids look you're he's actually right
we can't do it the same way they did
because we can't enslave that many
people yeah we don't really know how
they did it yeah we had no idea they did
it
how this means that we're Dumber now
like didn't they didn't the Egyptians
also think that the Earth is flat yeah
no they're right they never did oh did
they not it's not true uh it was
aristosthenes I believe who correctly
calculated the circumference of the
earth by comparing different shadows but
that actually works for the local the
Sun as well but last night Katie Faust
was saying or actually we were just
talking it came up that a lot of our
architectural genius is being placed
into video games now a lot of male
architecture mind space is being put
into video games and you're building
these these digital realities so
building gargoyles are being created
yeah free labor child labor on road oh
Roblox
my show idea and I've mentioned on the
show and I pitch I I go to Antarctica
yes we have to do it everybody's been
telling that absolutely absolutely but
my show idea was it takes place in the
last City and the people who live there
call it the last City and no one really
knows why human civilization collapsed
but all other cities on Earth are Barren
empty wastelands of Decay ruin cars just
falling apart it's like a
post-apocalyptic scene and
this city is has grown to a few million
people with technology somewhat
comparable but a little bit better than
ours and they have Scouts going out
doing missions to expand the territory
of the city and reclaim more farmland
and things like this and then one day
they come across weird tall or you know
yeah probably tall slender beings in
like white suits with like white helmets
and they get into a fight and these
Advanced beings like just energy blast
them and then what happens is these
These Guys in Expedition are like body
cam filming and it's being transmitted
back and they're like these these are
aliens or something and they must be
what wiped out human civilization
they've come back to kill us what what
and then it turns out it was my show
idea
spoiler alert if the shower gets made
it'll be run for you uh the the
Revelation is
at some point people started migrating
to the metaverse because you can connect
your brain and eat filet mignon every
night if you want forever you you you
don't live forever but like thousands of
years compared to 70 on Earth yeah well
no but expand time like yeah your mind
moves faster or whatever so when you're
when you're plugged into the metaverse
you can virtual reality you can
experience anything you want so there's
literally no reason to leave so they all
end up living in pods underground in
these facilities where in their they
experience life much like ours but in
base reality they never leave the Pod
and so the people who are the last City
don't know what happened because news
never stopped information as to why
humans migrated persists but it
persisted into the metaverse for humans
who are outside of that system and don't
have access to it they don't have the
historical records it just one day
disappeared so you've got mountain
people trailer park people these types
uh on contacted tribes who are outside
of the system and will never integrate
with it and then the people they
encounter in these suits every so often
metaverse people do have to go out to
maintain the machines they live in I
genuinely believe we are inching towards
living in the pot and eating the bugs
but it's not how people understand
you're going to come home from work or
whatever it is you have to do you're
gonna your house is going to be akin to
a pod outside with maybe like a plastic
Shield over it just for like nature
protection so you don't die from a bear
attack you're going to lay down in your
pod and then you're gonna go to sleep
and then instantly wake up inside your
Mansion you're gonna walk to your fridge
where you're gonna pull out a whole
cheesecake and just shove the whole
thing you're about to be like so good in
the Pod you've got cockroach slime going
into your feeding tube or whatever into
your neck port and you're not going to
care because your brain is being
stimulated in the metaverse it's even
worse Tim uh Alex Jones talks about this
and you can actually pull this up
because they want to have it when you go
to the metaverse so you can ejaculate 5
000 times a day that's what they think
that's what they think that they would
be doing in the middle verses
do that now
I don't think so you don't think that
they would immediately go hold on uh I
think if we did a show exploring a
future where people in the metaverse you
would have a portion where it's like oh
that's a sex club and and it's just
people saying they're going like that
yeah ejaculating will they be orgasm but
hold on hold on hold on let me ejaculate
for so long people would be wanting
dopamine releases in other ways the idea
that there are not all humans are
perpetually in the state of trying to to
achieve sexual activity says to me that
there would be people who do but most
people would stimulate themselves
through dopamine through the traditional
means meaning guys would go into their
own micro universes where their kings
saving the children from uh from a from
a fire or being they would make
themselves superheroes so they can
constantly get that that masculine
satisfaction it's not I I do not think
it's a bunch of guys being like I'm
gonna go and do this they would guys
would do this a lot me but I would say
99 of their time is going to be spent in
a fictional reality where they're the
superhero doing great things and
everyone loves them for for having done
it in the metaverse you think that's
what men would spend their time
Alexander the Great yeah and they're
men are gonna be like you know what
feels the best I gotta tell you yes guys
would love to do the weird creepy you
know fetish stuff but I I'd be willing
to bet more guys would want to be
catching the final touchdown pass at the
Super Bowl 60
000 people cha screaming and they're
just like yeah yeah everybody but then
all you want to do is bang after that
yeah after that you're right I switch
channels and then hold on and then all
the cheerleaders yeah on the field
this is just kind of to what you're
saying though and this is actually Ian
made a point about and it's funny that
I'm referencing Jake and Logan Paul but
when you're talking about the sex stuff
Jake Jake Paul is actually I just saw
this clip today he was on a podcast with
his brother and he made a good point
he's like the reason why this Dylan Dan
is stuff you guys have seen Dylan
Daniels no what is it so Dylan danis is
supposed to fight Jake Paul and Jake
Paul Logan excuse me fight Logan this is
Jake that said the same and I get him
confused but Dylan danis is fighting
Logan Logan Paul is engaged to a girl
named Nina Agdal she's been in Hollywood
for about 10 years maybe 12 years she
has a picture to him with every A B C D
and e-list celebrity that's ever even
been in Hollywood I mean she probably
has a picture with a thousand different
celebrities Dylan danis has been posting
these pictures like insinuating that
she's sleeping with all these people and
it's super viral I mean he's he's gained
about a million followers since he's
been doing this and Jake his brother was
talking to Logan about why it's so
successful or why Dylan's resonating so
much with people is because men are
scared of women like men are constantly
getting rejected by women they're
constantly addicted to porn they have
impotency problems so it's like the
sexual nature of man we're almost
becoming submissive to women in a weird
way and that's why they like this
because they like seeing a woman get
dunked on I disagree I think that the
majority of men are submissive to women
and that's why when you look at the
dating statistics of Tinder bumblebee or
I'm sorry Bumble whatever uh is that
women choose the top tier of men and men
will go for like the the bell curve and
male male perspective for attractiveness
is a standard bell curve and for women
it's a massive Spike towards the high
end of attractiveness and so if you look
at how other primate families do it one
powerful chimp for instance beats the
crap out of their chimps and then gets
all the women
so if you're if we're looking at modern
society I am not surprised to see that
there is you know a majority of men who
are anti-women no are unable to properly
uh woo a woman and then there's a small
percentage of guys who are getting all
the women that's like baser instincts
the small percentage of guys that are
getting all the women they don't have to
woo like if you're talking about the
dudes that are like like there's no
wooing it's like if you're one of the
like one of the top guys yeah they slide
in my DMs they're like please do it
slide my DMs right now all like these
super ripped Chad guys are like I'm
insatiable and I want you too well
that's why you never cyber sex with
anybody on the internet because I
guarantee it's a guy
I heard that's what Andrew Tate was
doing yeah he admitted it he and this is
the thing for all the Android tape Bros
I think it's you know some of the stuff
that he you know I I agree with but he
literally there's a video tape of him
saying I would go on these dumb girls
and I would be talking to the guys and
they would give me all their money and
they asked him like did you feel bad
he's like no oh and I'm like dude
that's disgusting first of all your
cyber sexing with dudes and then you
don't feel guilty at all that you're
taking all these money under false
pretenses that you're gonna hang out
with them that you're gonna see him or
that you have feelings for him so you
know Andrew Tate I'm not calling him
necessarily a bad guy but that is not a
good thing to do I'd love to see the
chat history on some of those oh they're
disgusting with like what was he typing
to another man you know he was typing
the nastiest stuff because he said it he
said that his brain was better at being
perverted than the girls so you know his
nasty well because guys I mean that's
just the way it is but I I actually am
more interested in talking about uh you
know like Ai and stuff than just what
guys want to do in their free time so
you know anyway a lot of it's connected
well it is yeah a lot of it is connected
Digital Sex man that's
so uh I was talking about this the other
day
the the place that mid journey is at
right now is just insane I posted I I
typed in on the show Nancy Pelosi
shaking hands with Vladimir Putin and it
made this photo of that of Putin smiling
and Nancy smiling and there's like
a demonic face on the wall and I'm like
how did it know to do this how did it
know to make it like creepy and evil
looking it just knew and people have
started taking these photos and turning
them into videos through an A through AI
making like three to five second videos
in a year we're gonna be getting five to
ten minute videos and it's going to be
really it's gonna be fantastic quality
video and then in a year or two we're at
the point where you're gonna have half
an hour to hour like videos with speech
like all the components already exist
chat GPT is there you can create
conversations all you have to do you can
do this right now with chat GPT when
they started doing what's called prompt
injection
where to break the rules they said they
get made this huge long text of uh a
long list of texts where it was like
from now on you respond to this you
behave this way you answer these things
and it cracked it it cracked chatbt so
that it started communicating like
something else
so I I explored this further and I
started giving it Personnel so like from
now on you are Donald Trump and it would
start answering my questions as if it
was Trump because of all of Trump's
speech and all of his texts and his
mannerisms are online and in the machine
so that means you could go in a video
game you could create a 3D avatar of
Donald Trump high quality 4K like any
other video game we have today and then
plug chat GPT into it and say hello Mr
President hello how's it going and it'll
actually be a like a facsimile Trump
having a conversation with you you can
do this for any character and it can
happen right now all that needs to
happen right now is the tedious effort
of a game developer being like I'm going
to put plug A and B together
because all the components already exist
when that happens I gotta tell you
you're talking about this freaky like I
just want to do weird stuff on the
internet they will do weird stuff in
these games but if you can if if you get
home from working at your burger joint
and you can turn the game on where
you're the football star catching the
touchdown pass to win the Super Bowl
people are going to create characters
who worship them who say everything they
want to say they're going to get their
dopamine release from fake people who
guarantee it to them it is like the
ratney experiment with the electron in
its brain hitting the dopamine button
over and over and over again yeah I do
think that is going to happen but I
think it's going to be a little farther
off than we think because there's a
thing called The Uncanny Valley where
even all of the biggest and I may have
said this on the show before all the
biggest telecommunication companies they
use they spend billions of dollars in
research and development to create
artificial intelligence so when you call
a call center you think you're talking
to a human and human beings when they do
this test Tim we always Pat we always
figure out we're talking to a robot some
people figured out it's just not good
enough it's just not good enough yeah I
know and actually there's a website I
think it's called um what was it called
is it called bot it's it's not called
bot or not but everybody figures out
usually within two minutes in a minute
yeah human or not so
I'm sorry you uh uh you can't figure
this one out that's cool let's see uh oh
it's over the experiment has ended so uh
the issue is
you think you're do you get to talk to
it you you are randomly placed into a
chat with another person okay and you
you are both given a certain amount of
time to respond to each other after a
certain amount of time it asks you was
the person you're talking to a human or
a bot and I don't know what their
results are but I can tell you this I
tricked a whole lot of people you did
and they thought they were talking to a
bot and they were talking to me who is
intentionally manipulating them like I
like it's really obvious to make it seem
like you're a bot and get them to pick
the wrong answer and there were there
were some times where you were doing an
inside job because you were playing a
human acting like a bot that's the point
of it I know you're trying to deceive
the other person to see what they choose
but they're trying to make robots sound
like humans right and so that's a
component of what these things do I
think it'd be harder for a robot to
actually sound like a human than would
be for a human to sound like a robot
humans can can uh create a facsimile of
a robot very easily and robots are
having a hard time right now emulating
humans properly yeah but we are not that
far off yeah I agree so there was a I I
called uh one of my one of the services
that I use everyone has some
subscription service and the person
answer was like hi thanks for calling
this is customer service how can I help
you and I said human being hey I can
answer your questions just give me a
chance I was like human being
okay well would you like to ask a
question and then I went for the
standard there's one thing you say if
you're tired of talking to the machine
now this was a text prompt like AI chat
language thing but it's just so obvious
about
do you know that there are two words you
can say that will instantly get the
robot to hang up and switch to a human
Donald Trump no operator nope that's
absolutely not I just say an over and
over operator I can say two words
instantly and get it get an operator
What any guess no any guesses two words
no two words I just violently tapped the
zero it's a zero give this a try the
next time you're on with a robot and
many of you will will notice you'll say
human being it'll go if you'd like a
question answered try asking me and
you'll be like representative I can
answer your question oh I tell you what
you say one thing you is it the
tone and that will instantly goes I hear
that you're angry I'll be getting a
representative for you
I can't say that every single system
does this I have been hung up on before
you know and it was just like I'm sorry
I can't help you goodbye and hangs out
that's what I usually yeah but I would
say 99 of the time I was on the phone
with um I think it was United
and they cancel they they switched me
off my first class ticket to a coach
garbage seat on a different flight
without my permission at four in the
morning so I showed up to the wrong gate
confused I'm like what's happening and
they're like we've we've decided
unilaterally to even though you paid
first class to move you to coach on a
different plane to a different city and
I'm like what but your ultimate
destination Remains the Same so it's fun
so I called and I and I get that hi
thanks for calling can I help and I went
you
transferring to a representative
instantly automated customer service
should be illegal that's a life hack I
gotta ask you guys yeah but then you're
just like like we'll be getting to you
in 17 hours yeah on AI and relationships
when you're in a V because right now I
got a video game called Baldur's Gate
three I just got it and in the game you
can one of your companions you can kind
of hook up with one of your companions
one of them yeah we get to hook up with
all of them
okay hold on hold on let me just add
this orgy commence I'm very interested
please Baldur's game is awesome it's
this new game that came out it's like
highly rated 10 out of 10 across the
board but because they wanted it to be
that everyone you you can be any
Identity or sexuality you want because
it's you every character has to have a
romance path which means
all like if you play as a dude and I'm
like bro I'm just like I'm a rogue
Street pickpocketer that's trying to
make my way through this crazy world and
all these dudes that are coming to help
fight the bad guy keep trying to have
sex with me and I'm like guys stop yeah
the guys are trying to have sexually on
the show that's right in the game wow
the guys the women the Bears you name it
they throw it at you and I don't know if
you can have multiple partners but
that's not the point the point was you
can't I'm pretty sure yes okay when it
becomes hyper realistic and you're in
like an AI environment and it's a woman
and you're talking to her and she's like
I want to have sex with you tonight is
that cheating on your wife
uh see this is a great hair you're just
gross have you guys have you guys seen
the uh episode of Black Mirror where the
two Bros from college get the new neural
video game and then they start having
sex with each other because like the the
one they play a fighting game and one
guy would choose the Asian martial
artist the other guy who's the Asian
lady so when these two adult black men
go into the video game and everything's
super realistic and they can feel
everything they just for some reason
start having sex instead which I'm
curious as to why the game programmers
put that in the game as a capability but
sure nobody I'm sorry dude if you made a
fighting game and then you're like but
you can also go in there and have sex
I'm pretty sure people would not be
fighting each other in that game but but
my point was just that that's the
premise of the episode that his wife
finds out and it is cheating and so the
agreement they have is that one once per
year he's allowed to go bang his bro and
then she takes off her ring and goes and
has a fling oh well it kind of it makes
you think about Christianity and Judaism
kind of a differential is that and I was
I think someone was talking about this
maybe it's Jordan last night Peterson
but that Chris it wasn't known as Dennis
Prager uh about Christianity is a lot
about your thoughts and policing your
mind and controlling your thoughts that
thinking of another woman is like is
adultery whereas Judaism is more about
your actions and it doesn't really
matter so much about what you're
thinking if you behave in a certain way
then you're living to God's standards
look I'll just play this and I wonder if
AI is a behavior or if it's just in your
mouth in your mind I will say I will say
yes if you are going into a neural link
virtual space to bang other women you're
banging other women what about you it's
like porn cheating because that's kind
of a gray area I've had this public
debate because well it's I'm not gonna
sit here in line and say I don't like to
look at a picture of some boobs
sometimes it's a gradient though right
there it's it's a hard line if you got
to figure it out figure it out for
yourself but the general idea is you
should be having relations with your
significant other and if you are if so
the way here's the way I view it if
we're able to go into an AI a matrix and
there was a fake woman that was created
or fake man that was created by the
machine that you knew didn't really
exist in real life
and people would be like oh it's just
like porn it's no different it's like no
no when you go to a bar and hook up with
someone you know you're not in their
mind like you're just looking for a
fling if you get a fling from you know a
fake person or a person you are still
cheating on your significant other like
you should be having relations with your
with your significant other you should
be but I'll tell you this maybe the
solution for some people is the spouse
and you go in together and have a whole
plethora of weird why is it so much
different for you if it's done in the
metaverse versus done in any other
things well for cheating is it cheating
to them and you can feel it you're
actually doing it oh yeah like in the
Innovative like I don't even I'm super
annoyed with Baldur's Gate for this
because I don't care about having a
romance with some like Devil Woman or
whatever I'm like whatever dude I'm just
trying to like fight this squid guy or
something like that and it's just like I
I'll you in the game you go to camp and
it's like are you sure you want to go to
bed people want to talk to you I'm like
I am not talking to these people because
everybody wants to have sex at the camps
you can you don't this is like sexual
indoctrination yeah I mean I don't know
they want the romance paths yeah and
making it for women
well I I it's I I don't know what the
point is like broken I'm telling you I'm
playing I'm playing a game where I fight
I throw fireballs and summon zombies and
stuff because I just wanna I wanna fight
a dragon you know I mean it's like it's
fun to like level up your guy get
stronger and then you defeat the dragon
the last thing I want to do is go into
the camp I'll tell you what I did though
there's one relationship in that game
that is a must and it's when you rescue
the dog and you play fetch you get the
spell of animal speech and then you walk
up normally walk up the dog he's like
you give you pet him and then he brings
you stuff he'll like and then you could
throw the ball and then I got a potion
of animal speech and there's like hello
friend I hope you're doing well and then
I was like I'm sorry about your master
but I'm glad that we're friends like I'm
glad we're friends too and then you Pat
them I'm like that's the only
relationship that matters oh that's
definitely a game to try when I get back
to New York City yeah it's fun you meant
oh yeah it is pretty good apparently
Starfield not yet well so
it's good it's just there's a lot of
perk wall hey but let's talk about this
because so I I did beat it and then I
read the reactions people had to the
ending that I did and it's I think
Baldur's Gate three made a huge mistake
with one of their story lines which
allows you to I would say legitimately
beat the game in five hours or less
probably less and uh I decided to just
reload and purposefully lose to advance
the story and I just think it's it's
nothing ever yeah I tend to play those
games just to experience the game like I
don't look for a victory I just want to
do the quests and explore the you're
like me I like the side quests yeah the
cool game side quests pretty much but
you made a good point like if you're in
a video game and you're like the red
square and it's like the dialogue says I
am having sex with you now yes in the
red the blue square the green square
comes up and then you see like a DOT go
back and forth between the squares
that's not really cheating on your wife
right but if it's a fully looking
no I I think I think I think haptics
would be more akin to like using a toy
I'm talking about if you can plug in the
norlink to your brain and then you feel
the world like you do you go into a bar
and there's a bunch of AI you know
floozies and you're like let's go I'm
like that's Jets cheating well what's
worse because all women that have jobs
have a work husband and you know they'll
might have a boyfriend yeah most women
do you probably do I don't know well I
don't know I don't know what's a work
husband like you know somebody at work
that you're friends with you know
usually a lot of times girls become got
you know friends with a guy and it's
kind of their you've never heard that
term uh requestsman well that's like a
common term uh and it's really become
even more popular lately and oftentimes
it's like what's worse the emotional
cheating of them becoming best friends
or like her having a one night stand one
time never again or her having a guy
that every morning is giving her coffee
and the second tour that's worse yes
I wouldn't want my wife to bang some
other guy I'd rather have a friend at
work simple question when a guy is angry
that he's friend zoned
the issue is not that they're friends
it's that he wants more so if you have a
significant other who's giving you the
more you ask for and then his friends
the guy who's in the friend zone like
he's in the in the crummier position
people have emotional connections to
lots and lots of people personally I
kind of feel like if you're in a
relationship with someone
I mean my like I don't hang out with
anybody else like me and my girlfriend
literally just do everything together
and it's it's like there's I I don't
call anybody else I have no I don't know
that's just me but that's weird there's
relationships where girls have like best
friends or I'm not a fan of that yeah it
would be like this doesn't work for me
but with for me and my girlfriend if if
like if I'm not working we are going out
together to hang out to like she plays
poker with me we'll build both the table
and we do everything if we were just
talking about this earlier and I feel
like I need a therapist with my
girlfriend to be able to have this
conversation without going at her like
at each other about it but like women
don't understand or or tend it seems
like they don't quite understand that
guys want to have sex with them that is
in the DNA that men physically if they
become close to a woman friendship-wise
oh right right there's going to be a
desire to have sex and a willingness to
women absolutely understand yeah but a
woman knows within 10 seconds if they
would bang a guy
no he's just a friend listen when they
have you as a friend or they have people
that are friend zoned what that is is
keeping the man in a position to do the
things a relation in a relationship
should the relationship that they're in
Fall Apart yeah it's called orbiters
yeah it's like it's like Orbiter the
first time it's like the the AAA team
like he might he's and he's staying
because he's hoping that he gets called
up to the big leagues or he's back
it's a horrible situation that's why if
a girlfriend zones you stop talking to
her like if you're interested in a girl
I agree and she friend zones you stop
talking to her but but because she will
she will extract from you even if she's
not intentionally a bad person you are
going to give her attention she is going
to accept it I don't even see it that
way like when I was younger if there was
that's the way it is though no no no no
but that's a bad way to look at it if
there was a woman I was interested in
and she was like you know I'm not
interested you I'd be like I just want
to let you know I am but clearly there's
an impasse here and I think this is is
like that sounds healthy that's exactly
how I deal with it I'm like that's good
I just feel like hey look you're that's
cool go do your thing yeah I'll see you
around yeah that's I'm out that's the I
mean that's the right thing to do and
there's no reason to be to be women
women are allowed to not like me do you
actually that's cool a long time ago
Ashley I think the first time you're on
the show if you thought men and women
could be friends you said yeah but that
the dynamic changes it's not like the
same kind of friendship that like a guy
would have yeah I mean like you said I
think most men there is some sort of
sexual tension there Aaron they would
sleep with most the women that they're
quote unquote friends with so it's
difficult to maintain long-term
friendships with men without them
wanting to so yeah a lot of men would
would sleep with women they don't like
as well yeah so yeah yeah
do you think it's ethical for guys or
girls that are in relationships to be
chatting uh text chatting with other
people of other Sexes I think it's fine
to have friends of the opposite gender
you know I'm not going all Mike Pence
there but the Pence rule Works what is
the pins Rule gay conversion therapy
works I love that
very successful gay conversion therapy
my producer Jimmy I put him through it
and it actually works so go ahead sir I
don't know if it worked for jimmaine but
um Mike Pence he was in the headlines I
don't know this was probably six years
ago now because he won't go to dinner or
do anything with another woman if his
wife's not also present and you know
there's also some people in our industry
and in our field they won't go to events
without their husbands because they
don't want rumors and I totally
understand if I like if I won't like if
I'm on tour or whatever I don't go out
to do anything with only a female ever
at all period never ever ever it's the
only way to avoid accusations no I
totally understand the texting is what I
feel like it's Insidious I'm from the
generation before the internet like in
the early 90s late 80s you didn't have
text it was either you you called a girl
on the phone which if I had a girlfriend
I called another girl would be cheating
uh or if I would have to go to her house
to see her and if my girlfriend didn't
know that I was going to a girl's house
to talk to her that'd be cheating so
Phil you're the only one here that I
think is older you're older than me I I
find that it's so casual kids are like
or people that are used to the internet
is like I'm just texting it's just
texting I don't even know I don't even
like the guys all about the person yeah
all about the individual I don't think
there's an issue with texting someone
unless you're hiding it from your
significant other and your significant
other doesn't know about that I think
you know a lot of these conservatives
make fun of these dudes who are like
polycules or whatever with like a big
fat woman and they'll be like you know
you see these videos where it's like a
morbidly obese woman and like five guys
behind her and she like we're all in
this together and it's like
conservatives make fun of that and I'm
like I really don't think they care like
these dudes live this world they they
live this world it's just that's it I
think some of these guys might be
unhappy and would probably prefer
something better but like it's the same
thing with Chelsea Handler saying that
she wakes up at six in the morning does
drugs and masturbates I'm just like oh I
don't care she's probably happy I think
she'll be unhappy later in life when she
has no family and no one to take care of
her but come on the idea that she's
doing pure dopamine stimulation right
when she wakes up she's hitting those
those those dopamine centers she
probably feels great well it's funny you
say that because one a guy who I've
become very good friends with a guy
named Bubba Clem his name is Bubba the
Love Sponge he has a radio show and the
reason why he is one of the reasons he's
famous is he let Hulk Hogan bang his
wife oh Ryan the Hulk Hogan sex tape and
the reason why I bring a Bubba is he's
very masculine guy he's an alpha guy he
loves football this and that I would
have never expected him to be into
polyamory I'm not into it at all but
like you said Tim there are people that
are just into letting somebody bang
their wife
I'm just saying that's just what they
like it's not that I mean I'm not I'm
not I don't like that but some people
when he's a normal
self if you allow someone else to sleep
I don't think you're you're not it's not
your wife it's like
I'm not saying I agree with it but I'm
saying some guys like that that's just
what they they want to be a cuckold if
if
if you are in a position where your wife
wants to sleep with someone else and you
allow it to happen you are not really
married my wife and her boyfriend right
now are having a great time I don't I
don't care it is clear in law that the
word marriage as a legal concept doesn't
matter to what marriage actually is and
the fact that we are in a world of no
fault divorce means there's quite
literally no contractual marriage at all
a real marriage is when you and another
person actually have that commitment and
are knowingly married like you have a
commitment to each other till death do
us part this idea that people can go to
Vegas and be like we're married now it's
like no you're not dude that's not real
marriage but we do add our super chats
let's go to Super Chat smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the share with your friends and all that
jazz we're a little late but we'll read
what you got uh what's what is this Ben
says Tim please look up the clip of
Biden introducing secretary Booty Juice
it's a good laugh what yeah
what did he say to Booty Juice what did
he do what is it called in Booty Juice
was it an accident it was you know he
didn't say Buddha judge what did he says
then you slopped it out the way that he
slops all of his sentences out what is
it he said he was a professor for four
years at a school that he was only at
for two years he just said that yeah he
said he was like a tenured uh whatever a
professor or something like he said he
taught for four years he was only there
for two now that CNN and and the
mainstream media is actually collecting
these and putting putting them out so
that people can see them I actually like
Biden a little bit better just because
he's funnier well and honestly I'm
starting I'm starting to like Biden
because I know then I mean this is just
pure speculation they're going to put
Kamala Harris in the presidency I think
so you really think so I don't think so
she's so nice just for a month just to
do it and then they'll go back to Gavin
Newsom you know okay okay it might be
yeah just for like uh just the tip what
if they want her is Gavin's VP well I
wouldn't be surprised she's the best VP
that's like sloppy second has anyone
ever been vp'd to two different
presidents she she literally gave Willie
Brown the mayor of San Francisco BJ's
together okay come on so well that's I
think that's out in the open I think I
oh I don't know if that specifically
I think she dated Willie Brown and
dating is yeah you're building more
specific in there maybe they're waiting
till marriage all right let's get some
more here we go think on this as Hobbies
uh after all are what you spend your
free time on whether or not I'm sorry he
says uh misogyny may be too strong of a
phrase there but that is what women feel
when you belittle their differences
Hobbies after all are what you spend
your free time on whether or not they
benefit anyone I think this is a
reference to fresh and fit we're saying
that women don't have hobbies yes right
so like like what do you do for fun
Ashley I play video games right so you
have hobbies yeah what they were saying
is that and I my response to a lot of
their comments was like you guys
surround yourself with a very particular
group of women and they're like no these
are regular like college degrees Masters
whatever and they said that you know 80
of women will just be like when they say
what do you do for fun they'll go oh I
hang out with my friends and they're
like yeah but what are you doing when
you do it like what do you mean I go out
it's like what does go out mean like
what does that mean what do you do and
they're like what do you mean I go out
like I don't know what you're talking
about they're confused by the question
the answer was cocaine they just didn't
want to say it the answer was we go to a
bar and we sit there well they also
probably have other hobbies that they
wouldn't consider Hobbies like makeup
makeup's a hobby for a lot of women I'm
sure they're all um
getting dressed makeup is a hobby if
you're like mastering the skill of
applying makeup properly yeah but if
you're like passively putting makeup on
just to look good I wouldn't consider it
a hobby I don't think have you spent
significant time around women talking
about makeup with each other it is kind
of a hobby
I'm saying it can be a hobby if there's
a culture around it and like you're
describing it but I don't think I think
for a lot of them that's not the case
well this makes me I would just I think
most women think of makeup as a hobby
this makes me a simp on a blimp but I I
don't I don't like the new kind of
movement where it's like repeal the 19th
Amendment women shouldn't vote like I
just I think that's so dumb I mean I'm
not even trying to say a woman or it's
well it's a bunch of relationship advice
from single people do women apply makeup
for the pleasure gain from sitting there
putting on makeup and no other reason
yeah sometimes someone in that instance
I would say it's a hobby yeah but for
women who are like they they know makeup
or whatever that's like saying I I buy
vulcum jeans and I've talked to people
about my shoes so my shoes are a hobby
no they're not no no I guess it's just a
different culture right I collected
shoes my hobby would be shoe collecting
yeah so I think for what would you what
would you call that makeup collection if
a woman puts on makeup takes a picture
and then cleans it off hobby if a woman
just puts makeup on for the for the sake
of putting on makeup the same as anybody
puts on clothes or a shirt or whatever
my point is these women probably have
hobbies that they're not classifying as
Hobbies
I think it's fair to say that freshman
fits around themselves with a particular
type of woman so they're getting a lower
percentage of women with Hobbies
obviously they're women who are doing
sports they're women who skateboard
they're one who play poker but I think
any guy who's engaged in your your
standard most popular Hobbies women make
up you know one in five to one in ten of
the participants
sure they're acceptable hobbies that
fresh and fit likes no I'm talking about
what are the Hobbies of the men on fresh
and fit I'm I'm saying look at the top
commercial hobby activities
and women are a very small percentage of
participants if you look at things like
first of all if you look at news news
shows for instance do you watch the news
women the top hobbies are learning yeah
women hate women painting and women
writing and gardening actually these are
primarily female dominated the top top
Hobbies dance gardening photography
poetry and drawing but maybe whatever
the question is they ask what do you do
for fun oh yeah nobody would say like
I'm writing for fun women can just like
be whereas Men actually have to do
something to be what are you doing bro
well men do things like and not not for
nothing but like men that don't do
anything that sit on their butt
everybody looks at them like they're
just a pit pile dude it's like women
actually can be like well you know I
hang out with my friends and not do
things and they their value is intrinsic
because they're women men have to earn
value they have to do something to
become better it's so much that I'll get
a phone call from a guy and he'll be
like hey man what's going on I'm just uh
over here it doesn't wait for my answer
he's program to ask me what I'm doing
doesn't even wait for me to respond and
that's like the it's it's taking a place
for hello hey man what's up I'm just
over here talking and I'm like yeah do
you want me to tell you what I'm doing
you just asked me anyways let's uh we'll
read some more Super chats we got eye of
the storm says please read my chat this
is for Ian you're an awesome bro I pray
that one day I meet you and chill but
more importantly you should look up the
gift of the Holy Ghost In God wants your
life you gave me a compliment and they
told me to do something gift of the
ghost so I'm gonna do it but we will
meet one Jason Dixon says Tim please
shout out the Discord we are developing
the culture it's getting huge we welcome
like-minded people
yes so uh aside from the members only
shows that you can get as a member at
timcast.com Monday through Thursday we
do the live show we take about four or
five callers typically five callers
every night from the members to call in
and talk to us and our guests and then
the members have taken it upon
themselves to create their own after
show for all the people who want to keep
hanging out so I think that's actually
the biggest benefit of what we I think
we've accidentally built something
awesome
the goal was hey sign up and then you
can watch the show and then all of a
sudden the people who signed up started
talking to each other building things
with each other uh creating sharing
ideas and making their own platforms and
shows and so uh join join the uh the
membership and and meet more people in
your area and meet people who share your
ideas and make friends isn't it crazy
how like it was unexpected community
that was built and really just goes fits
right into the idea Bridget May says
they removed today's culture War we did
not uh it was live and then we ended the
live and then uploaded a full version
and so there is a the live streamed
version so I'll just put it this way I
got to keep it a little bit vague but
one of the challenges with a live stream
is that you can't change it so if you
want to trim or blur or add or anything
like that it's restricted and very
difficult to do so once the show ended I
was like let's just re-upload what's
called VOD video on demand version
instead of the streamed version which
gives us more controls over the whole
thing and uh it is there it is on the
page and people are listening to it also
it is on I believe it's up on all
podcast platforms yeah so you can check
it out and it was a really good one it
was um Katie Faust and Jeff younger and
we're discussing modern marriage
relationships parental rights and men's
rights and Jeff younger made a really
really great point he said his position
was we should we should uh women should
sign surrogacy contracts for their own
children so here's how it would work
you're a man and a woman and you are
going to have a biological baby that the
mother will conceive as the Bible
intended with the man but she signs a
surrogacy agreement like any woman would
do in an IVF surrogacy but then has the
biblical child
that way at any point the man can at all
points the man is in full control of
custody and rights at his favorite in
the courts and Katie was like no that's
horrible and then he asked would you
agree to a contract like that and she
was like of course not absolutely not he
goes you think any woman would and she
said absolutely not and he goes that's
exactly what the contract men sign when
they have kids with a woman today that
at any the courts favor the women women
uh 80 86 percent I think it is like 86
percent a woman can just take the child
away from the Father the Trope in
society is that when it when a fight
happens the man is forced to leave his
own home it's not absolute but that's
what it is and that was the point he
made I would just say I I was like I see
the logic in your argument and the
horror and the emotional like prospects
of what you're proposing but I get the
point he's trying to make he's saying
why would anyone agreed to be in a
relationship where you create a child
when you are in the negative in terms of
control over the raising of that child
it's like a fair point well Jeff younger
has a unique situation where one he has
two twins and then then the wife is
transitioning the other one and I'm not
even trying to throw shots at Jeff but I
guess I am going to throw a little bit
of shot um
I agree with a lot of what he says but
one of the his court cases was to not
talk about his custody battle and then
he talks about it and that's one of the
reasons he lost custody of his kids is
because he kept talking specifically
well I think it's because he kept making
it public so but I guess my point is I I
I I I would argue there's a strong case
he did the right thing yeah I think so
too but my point is if you're gonna say
oh I'm gonna follow the rules of a judge
you're that's the judge the judge you
don't get to have your kids I'm not
saying that's right or wrong I'm not
saying I think that totally wrong I
think the system screwed up what they're
doing at January 6th what they're doing
to him is screwed up but if you don't
follow the rules
you're going to lose custody of your
kids that's just yeah I think we're
getting into a very dangerous space when
it when a political cultist of a judge
and she is she is I agree is
like going to empower someone to
castrate your son we are getting into a
very very very very dangerous territory
that I hope we do not get into yeah no I
know if we are and I don't think that
these family courts these courts these
judges should have really any dominion
over our children but we've given them
that and that's the real issue with
family court and I think you know Jeff
obviously I'm sympathetic to his case
but I don't think it's helpful this
division of the Sexes and blaming women
and this and that because it really at
the end of the day the issue is that the
government is so hyper involved in
making these decisions for our children
when they shouldn't be and I want to add
too I'm pretty sure this is public
knowledge we talked about it uh hit the
mother of his kids is not actually the
biological mother yeah I know that's the
other word no I didn't know that right
she's she's a stepmother but she got
custody yes and fled to California I
think it was it was very weird it's very
weird I'm very empathetic to Jeff I'm
just saying when you're in a court
you're in a custody battle you know you
have to follow the rules whether they're
legal whether they're Fair that's just
the system all right we got we got one
of these guys artorius Rex says Tim frog
boiling in a pot was shown by goltz to
only work if you'll bottomize the Frog
intact frogs attempt to escape even in
slowly heating water oh we all know this
frog bowling a pot is just a turn of
phrase it is it is it is it is this it
is the meme version
I don't want to say the if we all sit
here allowing incremental change over a
long period of time we'll be oblivious
to the changes happening around us until
it's too late and then we we are
detrimentally negatively impacted I'd
rather just say we're frogs bowling in a
pot man we've got to make sure is it
meme it is a way to simplify an idea
into a phrase but yes it has long been
known frogs will try to escape just like
Lemmings don't actually walk off cliffs
yeah true unless you know Disney yeah
they pushed him off that was a great
everybody needs to look into that what
was the name of that video uh I don't
know the 70s look at Disney killing
Lemmings they were scaring them yeah and
they had a camera like underneath the
ledge so I mean that's ridiculous yeah
that's so messed up
Anastasia B says guys I'm seven years
sober today dude congratulations
congratulations
glad to hear it we sound like an AAA
meeting we're like but that is
incredible keep up the good work
neglectful sausage says every single one
of you in here pays thousands of dollars
a year in cool new apps and phones to
support surveillance State stop
pretending your Rebels that's the
banality of evil yeah and also I think
it's uh
like an over dramatically over dramatic
simplification of any and all of our
positions we also want to know who what
device you use to type that Super Chat
on and it's not it's not just that it's
like bro you can be a rebel in a system
like I don't understand what you're
saying I I I I am not an advocate for
people abolishing cell phones and
capitalism I'm in favor of Technology
technological advancement I would just
like there to be alterations to the
current way we're going about doing it
in fact if something if someone came out
like we're getting rid of all
smartphones I'd be like I'm okay
like I think it's been bad across the
board if that's what we got to do but uh
yeah if everyone is mindlessly Marching
In lockstep and you're still you know on
the field in which they are Marching and
you're walking somewhat in the general
direction while telling them not to walk
that way but to turn right like you are
rebelling I don't know it's not that
complicated you don't have to act like
every single act of rebellion is not
shaving your armpits throwing your phone
at the wall and going living under a
bridge because like because modern you
know modern homes man they put your name
on a list and the government stores at
the records and then all of a sudden
it's in Google and everyone knows where
you live and they're tracking your data
so the only way to get away from it is
to go come on the argument would be
you can't rent because you got to put
your name on the piece of paper you
can't have an ID it's like bro we can we
can reject and resist you don't have to
you know be a caveman I think a lot of
good can come from tools that are
derived through evil actions like um you
know some warmonger gets a bunch of
slaves to make a bunch of guns and then
you break out the guns and the slaves
and use those same guns to overthrow the
slave master for instance but I think
that a lot of times evil uh actors will
use that premise to do evil thinking
that later they're gonna do good with
this evil action and it's a dangerous
path but it is possible it's important
to be civilly disobedient and one thing
is that the FBI and NSA supposedly even
if your computer as long as it's plugged
into power and your TVs that they can
hack into everything so I mean you know
we can't live in a world where there's
no surveillance this is important just
me says the Trump Revenge photo got me
reported to HR at a company I have
worked at for 10 years fighting for my
job now sounds like you got a lawsuit on
your hands wow for having a picture of
trump and saying Revenge
depends on where you worked man yeah but
uh I would like to hear more I don't
know anyway you're saying something Phil
uh I don't remember you said it sounds
like a lawsuit in the making no before
that he was saying something I was like
wait I gotta read this
what do we got more Super chats
what is this
poppinspatches.com says Alex Stein is so
on fire that not even a Nebraska
downpour last year could stop him from
Spitting Fire thank you Tim can Public
Square have an airsoft field
public so uh I oh we gotta be careful
here
I don't you don't ask me about anything
I'm gonna do a Public Square the idea is
we're we're gonna we're gonna be
building an anti-time Square Ian said we
should call it Public Square yeah like
that's up to them lowercase p unless
they want to to be uppercase P well
because Times Square was named for the
for time times of the world or whatever
which is the New York Times I believe
and uh so this we want to do uh uh
you're going to love this we got to have
an Alex Stein location or whatever yeah
please so we've got a Casper coffee shop
okay we want to build a cousin T's Diner
we want oh yeah and then Jackson yeah
yeah I saw this I wanted my pillow brick
and mortar location where you can go in
and they got the bathrobes and the
towels the slippers the pillows I think
that's easy especially because their
inventory doesn't I wonder if we could
open a Jeremy's we should have it it'll
just be like Jeremy's razors Jeremy's
chocolate Jeremy's products should have
a store where they have room
and they have the daily wire playing it
and all the stuff they sell and their
merch I want the prime time rage room
where you just go in and you break
anything let's do it yeah no for sure
and we'll have like a cartoon picture of
your Facebook like yeah you'll get a
mallet you can break anything printers
we can recreate office space just we're
gonna be able to bring your own stuff to
break though yeah well we'll have some
stuff but again you want to bring like
you know your ex-wife sold you know some
some of her favorite uh China you can
just break that yeah they have these
these rage rooms yeah but so uh we're
we're actually having a meeting about it
next week and uh We've invested a lot of
money already I think it's fair to say
that our investment is around a couple
million dollars in getting started and
uh it's big it's going to be big
everyone agrees it's going to be the
best but just think how cool it's going
to be when you're right yeah uh daily
wire having a storefront location where
they sell razors memberships chocolate
anything else they do uh uh you know
some we gotta have a bar set up
somewhere maybe Southwest opens a bar
yeah the ultra dad's bar whatever and
he's got his beer there and then what it
is people will come as tourists because
all of your favorite shows and and
people have their businesses here to
create a space where you can support
businesses you care about up Ian had the
idea of calling it Public Square I hit
Public Square the Public Square guys up
Public Square should have one of the
biggest storefronts where all the
different products can be purchased like
a big you know like you go to the
Hershey's store and they have all the
candy everywhere you go into the public
store the Public Square store and all
the different Public Square companies
have products and you can walk up and
they've got they got it all man and if
there was a literal Square there in the
center where with like a big plaque on
it that has the directions to all like
the different restaurants and shops and
stuff around you can go look at the map
or it could be a digital map I think
you'd also have it on your phone there's
a we're a long ways from that for a few
reasons the most important thing is that
there's a historical society and the
first the first
um
Primary Law and all of this is to
protect and preserve the generational
businesses and historical buildings
because we want we want to be the
opposite of Times Square we do not want
to be a commodified billboard garbage
advertising thing of massive faceless
corporations we want American values we
want to restore a lot of the places a
lot of the buildings we got to build a
big fountain
well I don't know I'm just saying some
running water we are not going to go in
and put up signs and do whatever we're
going to work with the people who are
there to what best suits their needs and
revitalizing these particular areas
while bringing in companies that believe
in American America's values and
investing in the space and cleaning it
up there are a lot of people in the area
that we're looking at who've got
generational businesses and I want to
see them become like they will be it is
it is they're the reason this this
matters someone who inherited their
store from their mom who got it from
their grandmother who got it from the
you know great grandmother and then
revised revitalizing the areas restores
that business and you know provides
wealth and means to the family who's
been there for generations and you know
that I I want to you know we got a great
plan for this and we're just getting
started it's probably amazing the
biggest threat well one of the largest
threats is two but making too much too
fast just like immigration you can't let
in too many people too quick can really
change the dynamic of an environment so
uh but I think we can do it Ryan
Sergeant says Michelle Obama and VP
Newsom I don't think so I don't see
Michelle Obama I don't know I don't
either yeah I do think Joe Biden will
drop out in some way I don't know I I
just I I don't see how you have Nancy
Pelosi on CNN being like what if Joe
Biden doesn't run because I I hope he or
what if he does what if he drops down
she's like I hope he doesn't you know or
I hope he would you say I should hope
she does he doesn't drop out and Gavin
said the same thing she hope he runs oh
oh I don't know I want to be careful how
she phrased it right but the general
idea of what she said is there is a
concern she has that Joe Biden drops out
and I'm like they're priming us with the
distractions and now we're getting with
the impeachment stuff I don't see a
logical path for them to run by and I
feel like they have to drop he has to
drop out there's no way they're gonna
let him run in 2024 right I mean I
completely agree
well we'll see we'll see let's uh let's
maybe grab one more
Joe's Rusty races Glenn Beck can have a
museum in Public Square would be super
cool that'd be really cool all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com not just
for the after show not just for the Tim
cast after dark members only Discord
show where like-minded people hang out
and discuss the topics but hang out join
so that you can hang out with all the
other like-minded individuals where you
can become friends meet people Network
build resources share resources it's a
really fun you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Alex you want to shout
anything out I want to shout out Dylan
Keller Dylan the villain Keller and
watch my show on Blaze TV Primetime with
Alex Stein hit the link youtube.com
Primetime Alex Stein
just get the Babylon bees guide to
gender thanks for having me Tim sorry
I'm a little tired today oh you're tired
oh yeah I got the energy drink here
those are good like an hour I'm trying
yeah I am Phil that remains on X I am
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
follow us on Spotify Apple music Amazon
music Pandora YouTube you know the
internet hit me up at Ian Crossland
anytime anywhere on the internet you
know where to find me have a nice
evening catch you later and I am
search.com also a surge in real life too
so finally on Twitter let's argue etc
etc all right everybody thanks for
hanging out it's been a great week we're
gonna have Clips up throughout the
weekend and then we're back on Monday
and we'll see you all then